good morning everybody
will call this meeting of the house
Judiciary Committee to order
and perhaps we will begin with a pledge
of allegiance to the flag which is
located over there and representative
trottier would you mind leading Us in
that
um
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation indivisible
Justice
thank you
before we begin I just want to indicate
that we have a aggressive schedule
hearing schedule for today and for
tomorrow we have 10 bills scheduled
today five in the morning five in the
afternoon and the same for tomorrow
we've front-ended the the bills as much
as possible to hear them and I've tried
to put on the earliest bills the bills
that I think can be heard in a in a
timely manner
the and without extensive testimony
the
I plan I have already submitted the
bills for next week we'll also have a
number of bills for next week there'll
be eight on Wednesday and eight on
Thursday we have a total of 44 bills
that have been assigned to the committee
that so at the end of next week we will
have heard 36 of them
um the other remaining eight bills are
all bills which I think will have long
hearings and so we I've set them off at
the end
and we'll plan for that I did say that
we would have an executive session on
the 26th but uh
my vice chair is going to be unavailable
on the 26th so we may schedule hearings
that day as opposed to having the exact
session and we may have
an exact session that following week
which would be the first week in
February on February
2nd and 3rd
and what I was thinking of perhaps doing
was setting aside
one day for either party to caucus that
day we perhaps could have a caucus in
person that day because we're going to
have
at that point in time as many as 40
bills to look at and then a second day
where we'll have a full day of executive
session which I think might work out
well for everybody and at that point in
time if there needs to be
subcommittees established we can do that
and
and or work sessions we can plan to do
those as well
we have some
people who are absent today a number of
people who are absent today
Representatives Smith who everybody
knows had a bad fall is going to be
unable to be with us probably for two
weeks because of her fall
um representative McLean representative
Andrus and representative
merner are not going to be able to join
us today and have indicated
I also recognize that everybody has
bills as they've sponsored and they may
have obligations in other committees and
and
you're not going to pay any disrespect
to this committee if you go to your
other hearings and speak to your bills
so unless there are any other
administrative issues then we'll begin
our hearings
we do Mr clerk would you like to call
the roll
I thank you
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman are
you here I am
representative Sylvia here
Quirk is here representative Alexander
representative green
it's not here now representative
naughter
representative Kelly
it's not here representative trottier
yeah
representative Burch not here
representative Oregon
representative diorenzo representative
Chase representative Kenny
representative Langley
representative Macbeth
representative page
and representative Simpson
okay we have that
thank you Mr Clark
our first item of business is House Bill
1006 relative to disclosures required
prior to solicitations made on behalf of
law enforcement agencies
I don't have any pink cards the okay
are you representative Gallagher
okay representative Gallagher
and when you complete your testimony
could you fill out a pink card and get
that to us
um yeah if I could borrow from someone
um
so yeah I'm
uh representative Eric Gallagher
Merrimack County district 15 that's
Concord Ward 6.
um so
this bill is about
police officer associations
calling and asking for money I'm sure
you all have gotten calls like that
before
um
they where police officer associations
someone will call and
tell you about all these things they
need money for
um
so
solicitation in general is one thing but
um
the thing that makes police officers
associations different is
their association with the state people
could hear the word
police and
just that association with state power
the power of the state behind it
could lead them to think oh no I'm in
trouble with the police or something
I'll be in trouble if I don't donate
so
and that could lead them to thinking
that
the police are nothing more than just a
big extortion wreck it there's something
which is not what we want people to be
thinking
so
yeah my um
so my first preference
um
so would be just to ban the cause
entirely but that would probably run
afoul of freedom of speech
um freedom of speech Provisions in the
Constitution so instead of restricting
speech I am to solve the problem by
adding more speech and
having the police officer associations
be
clear about who exactly they are
they're not the police themselves
they're
a non-profit associated with them and
that people are
free to refuse to donate and they're not
in any trouble legal trouble and
shouldn't be afraid or anything so
hopefully that will
make the experience of
receiving these phone calls less
nerve-wracking for
everyone involved so
that's why I introduce this bill
and I'll take any questions
from the committee
yes
hi I'm just curious have you talked with
the the people who do these calls and
gotten
any feedback or have you just uh I mean
not about the bill specifically
I mean I have when I've received the
calls I've asked them
to stop calling many times and they
wouldn't
so
that's why
I felt the need to go
ahead with this bill rather than just
trying to solve it at the interpersonal
level
question
isn't is isn't compelling speech as much
a violation as the first amendment as
restricting speech
well we do it in we do it in other
situations where it's been allowed such
as
the you know this ad
I I'm so and so that I approve this
message on political advertisements and
you know nutrition labels on food
and
and all other sorts of it's this is put
into
um a section of the rsas about other
disclosure requirements for phone calls
so there's already other disclosure
requirements
that other solicitors have to follow and
this is just
making it stricter
for the specific case of police officers
representative Alexander
yes oh awesome thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question
um I'm curious on how you arrived to
specifically just law enforcement
agencies
um the reason why I'm asking that is
because we have other groups like for
instance political parties that might
call to call somebody and say you're at
risk of losing your sustaining
membership status and you should you
know donate immediately you know it
could scare you know a voter into
thinking they're losing some sort of
status so my question is like how you
specifically got to just law enforcement
well so the difference between
law enforcement and a political party is
that
so
the state has a monopoly of violence
like that's how it was defined as in the
legitimate use of force so um
the yeah police
um
and political parties political parties
generally don't
go around
um armed like
police police officers do and it's that
association with state power
now if political parties
started like employing their own private
security forces then yes I would be
worried about them too but so far that's
not really something we've been seeing
we've just been
seeing
um
so so far it's still the case that the
police are the main enforcers of the
States Monopoly of violence
representative De Lorenzo
um
okay wouldn't it be easier if um
a written disclaimer was required
um
in reference to this bill to say
something like um
this is you are not required to
um
donate and whether you donate or not
this will have no effect on your
personal
itself
so I guess my main question in response
to that would be how would a ran
disclaimer be provided if it's a phone
call we're talking about
um
you know that that would have to be
that would have to be sent separately in
the mail I guess and if people want to
cut the conversation off before it even
gets to the can I mail you a card or
something step then they wouldn't get
that notice
representative Horgan do you have a
question
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
very much representative Gallagher
because I think the most recent calls
are I got on behalf of the police
um
and it was easy to say no because the
caller was actually a robot was um
for a pack you know political action
committee and I think it was a federal
pact too so is your intent
to cover those along with the other
various other entities that
um
purportedly represent the police who uh
who call us on the phone and try to get
money out of us
um so yeah
um if there's some ambiguity about what
counts as a police or law enforcement
Association I would welcome an amendment
to
clarify the language around what counts
as that and what doesn't I think in your
particular example that that would count
um since it's yeah it does say police
but um
yeah I I do agree that could be
clarified right thank you thanks
for questions
I did have a question and
in the
what would be required for them to say
is that they clearly identify themselves
and I'm not exactly sure what that means
typically when you get a call they say
we're calling from the
police benevolent Society whatever else
what does clearly identify themselves
does that mean individually
how how would they clearly identify
themselves
um
so yeah again
this is
um
if you think that language is unclear
I'm willing to reword it a bit
um
for
yeah I think
just saying
um
who yeah who who they are who they're
with
um
yeah I guess I'm actually not too clear
on that myself sorry about that
what was your intent
um
well
yeah normally I mean normally people say
their own name when they're calling
on some um making a phone call hi I'm
Eric Gallagher I'm calling about such
and such
um
so yeah if they if they could include
their own name that would be good
would you believe that it's not uncommon
for people to use pseudo names when
they're doing those types of
um
well
yes
um
so
um I'm not really sure how to how to um
to address that
in the wording though like
if
if they're going to use a suit on him
like there's not really anything you can
do about that is there
um
that that would just be in violation of
this I think
representative
I size with um your bill I get it
because I got an invitation in the mail
from the police department to go to an
open house and my husband handed me the
letter and said the police are looking
for you and you get that what'd I do
yeah but as far as phone calls go and
rather than having legislation just
don't answer the phone screen your calls
goes right to voicemail
well
um I mean yeah you can do that with a
cell phone but um
for those of us with outdated technology
like so I live in an apartment complex
where there's a buzzer to let people in
and part of the agreement is that you
have to have a landline phone
um
to for the buzzer to be able to work to
be able to let people in the main
apartment door and
um
all I have for it's hard to find
landlines these days like I can't
um I have to use this old
receiver
from
um
from my pair that's a hand-me-down for
my parents that you know it doesn't have
call screening or anything on it so
you know you have to weigh that
you have to weigh
when you got phone calls from them like
oh well maybe it is actually something I
need to take since I'm expecting a call
from
so and so versus oh no is it just
another person asking for money so that
yeah there are still cases where
people can't necessarily screen their
calls
representative trottier
Gallagher
um
are you aware that these non-profit
agencies that are trying to solicit
money
have to register with the state prior to
being allowed to do that
um
yeah I think that was mentioned in
I think that was mentioned in the RSA
and I think that's
um
I think that's additional information
that could be helpful for people to know
and
these phone calls
so that way
that way if there's some sort of part of
the
they they have to make some sort of
agreement when registering right about
what they're going to do with this
registration so
um if people know that they have a
chance to
report that they're violating the terms
of whatever they signed up for when
they're registering that would be
useful for people to know
I have another question and at the end
of what you've added in as language it
says and that the individual has the
right to refuse to be contacted at a
future time yeah
the right to refuse is different than
requiring them not to call you
so
is there something in there that would
prevent them from being able to call you
again
um
yeah um
at one point in my own version of the
text I was drafting I also had a
requirement saying that um
well there's the federal do not call
there's the federal do not call list
right and um
people making calls are supposed to are
supposed to abide by that so
um I was trying to go for something
similar
to that so
in terms of
it being enforced I'd look um
I I imagine it would work some like
somewhat like that does
there any other questions
if not
thank you representative Gallagher thank
you and please get your pink card in for
us
for our records
is there anyone else who would like to
testify
on House Bill 1006.
seeing no one we will
close the hearing
just have a couple of minutes to go
until our next hearing scheduled hearing
time
if there are people who are here to
testify in house bill
10 20 you should fill out your pink card
if you haven't done so already and
send it up to the chair
thank you
good morning Mr chair and fellow
representatives of the judicial
committee
today I would like to present
um house bill
1020 in reference to additional
emergency lighting on
police and fire vehicles
so my main intention with this bill is
to bring it up to Federal standards
whereby
um
police vehicles can add a red light to
the left hand side of the vehicle which
my intent is the driver's side and fire
apparatus can add a single blue light to
the right rear side of their apparatus
um which is going to be the passenger
side
there's a few reasons that I am bringing
this forward
number one is to bring up the federalize
standards and also there are other law
enforcement agencies that travel
throughout the country
um like the sheriff's department
to do transports of prisoners and some
states do not recognize the lighting
system of of New Hampshire some States
run blue lights for their fire in red
red lights for the police so that's why
I'm bringing this forward
um and it's um
for any police and any of the vehicles
have to be either owned or leased by the
municipality
County or state law enforcement or fire
services
in my bill
um
no personally owned
vehicle that is being used as a call
member or for fire service will be
allowed to put a blue light of any type
on their vehicle and a
that's fire and on police they are not
allowed to put a red light on their
personally owned vehicle this way we can
tell police and fire
um I'm not familiar with many law
enforcements if there's any in the state
of New Hampshire that are using the
personal vehicles for law enforcement
um
so my goal is it with this bill is to
bring it up to
um Federal standards
I do have an amendment
um which will be Amendment uh
two zero two
two-018 which I realized in the original
um Bill there was a mistake that said it
show allow
private vehicles to be um
allowed to put a blue light and this
bill this amendment will just change
that saying is she'll not permit a
privately owned vehicle to put a blue
light
for a fire service
and that's pretty much the gist of this
bill
representative Chase
thank you representative chartier so is
this something that
the all the other states have first and
also is this going to be so if these
were changed would we the public
understand what these lights are or is
this more just for responders to
understand what you're transporting
thank you for your question currently
this is going to bring it to a
standardized requirement in New
Hampshire I have seen many law
enforcement agencies and fire agencies
putting these lights already on
but there's no standardized reasoning
when they do it I have seen police
vehicles with red and blue
across their whole light bar and I have
seen
fire apparatus with blue
um on either side
so I'm hoping this will standardize that
and I really don't think it's going to
make
um
much change I mean because I believe
that a lot of the public
already sees this in their communities
or throughout the state
representative Lorenzo thank you Mr
clear representative
um when we're talking about light bars
and lights are we talking about
permanently affixed or the ones that
people just attach to their groups no
these are permanently fixed Lighting
systems as you've seen either the light
bars on the roof or the ones that are
above the visor on the Windows front and
back
thank you you're welcome thank you for
the question
representative Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
I'm still not clear
why we need this and again who are these
codes for are they for other responders
are they for the public to know oh
they're transporting a prisoner or oh
they're going to a fire
um
what's the reason
number one is the federal standards and
basically I just I have seen again like
I said that a lot of agencies are
already running
different light colors
um in their light bars or their lighting
apparatus and I'm just trying to
standardize it so I just don't like
seeing you know like a cruiser having
four red in the front across the whole
bar in four blue so I'm trying to
standardize it that one side
is completely
um
no matter which like a left will be for
the red for a law enforcement vehicle
and the blue on the back of a fire
apparatus
thank you representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
do you intend by this to have uh
modifications made to existing vehicles
um my bill says
it's not a shell it's the agency May so
it's going to be the
choice of the agency but if they do have
um
their
patent different than what's required
they would have to move the lenses or
the light
after effective date
representative Langley welcome
you go with the federal standard
ly
I cannot answer that question I'm sorry
thank you
hello
questions representative Alexander
um I don't believe there there was a
fiscal note on this bill
um
someone goes
too much
and where it's not a man a mandatory
mandate it's going to be up to the
community or the agency if they want to
do that
right so just follow up the Mandate
would come after the effective date so
the Mandate would say that if if there
were lights that weren't following
that standard they would have to change
it so the the Mandate would come after
what what would be the cost if
to like change lights around on a
vehicle I don't have that okay thank you
other questions representative De
Lorenzo thank you Mr Shannon
I have representative so does that mean
that all new
place and fire vehicles after this bill
is passed would have to have that
standard it does not say that in the
bill it says they may choose to do that
pattern so if a police department says I
want to be strictly blue
they can do that
or if a fire department says no I want
all my lights red they can do that but
if they decide to do a red light on a
law enforcement vehicle it does have to
be on the left hand side or the driver's
side of the vehicle and fire wrappers
apparatus would have to be on the right
rear
thank you
other questions
I had a couple questions and and you
already mentioned the issue of
uh what is the left or what is the right
um are you going and it depends on which
end of the vehicle you're looking at so
are you going to do an amendment to
clarify that
yes Mr chair
this representative Sylvia
thank you and uh sorry if this has
already been asked um is there a
currently in the law is there a
Prohibition on doing these various
lighting schemes
not that I'm aware of
thank you
representative another question and that
was since the intent as I understand it
is to have our state comply with Federal
standards
would it be easier to Simply refer
in our statute that we have to comply
with Federal standards as as opposed to
trying to set it out this way
that might be a little easier Mr chair
I can explore that and have an amendment
done
and I guess the other question I had was
it says privately owned vehicle and
you're putting in an amendment in the
second part of that but privately owned
Vehicles shall not be permitted to a fix
red lights in accordance with this
paragraph
it says in accordance with this
paragraph but
are private vehicles at all allowed to
have red lights or
or blue lights yes
Mr chair I believe in that if you look
under that paragraph
um that would fall under
paragraph two
um
police vehicles so any privately owned
vehicle that is used
to do any law enforcement cannot affix a
red light
because the standard has been for the
volunteers or call members that red
lights
um
are there
because of to be used
if I could just follow up so would it be
better to clarify that it says privately
owned vehicles used for law enforcement
shall not be permitted as opposed to
just private vehicles that
wouldn't be able to use it ordinarily
anyway
yes
any other questions Mr chair yes thank
you representative page thank you
representative for taking my question
um when and forgive me for my ignorance
on the federal standards which for these
men or are these
I believe it comes under
um
Transportation I believe that's where
it's located but I would have to do a
little more research to confirm that
okay
all right thanks
other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you
and is there anything else who would
like to testify on House Bill 1020.
seeing none we will close the hearing on
House Bill 1020.
We're not scheduled to for our next
hearing until
10 o'clock
Mr chairman
I have a text from representative
Marjorie Smith and she's said that she's
do you know if that's all of us or
else you just said um I appreciate a few
folks would speak louder so I think all
of us
I think we can do that we can
accommodate representative Smith by
trying to speak a little bit louder
just for the committee's benefit I'd let
you know that we do have timelines and
the timeline being the
uh the tenth of
uh being the 17th of February to have
out any bills that need to go to a
second committee and we only have one
bill which we already have scheduled to
hear in the next either today or
tomorrow
that needs to go to a second committee
and then we need to have all the bills
out by
St Patrick's Day by March 17th
yes
welcome representative Muse
thank you thank you
um I'll keep things relatively short
this is a relatively uh simple bill that
increases the maximum recovery amount
per claimant in the the state victims
compensation fund from 40 to 50 000
dollars
it also extends the repeal date of the
frm recovery
contribution Recovery Fund a full year
from July of 2023 to July of 2024. one
of the other things that it does is it
specifies that any money that is left
over in the fund at that time would go
back into the victims compensation fund
so other victims of crime can be
compensated
um something that is important to know
is that outside of frm money for the
victims compensation fund uh is not
taken from the general fund this is an
established fund that's operated by the
State Attorney General's office
the money that that pays for other
victim compensation
consists of money from restitution from
fines and things of that nature
and this is a program that has made a
big difference in the lives of of
victims of crime over the years and I
would ask for your support
are there questions for representative
Muse representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative
um was there some sort of need to extend
it to the like 10 000 more dollars I
guess I'm wondering like what can what
spurred you know the increase here
um to be honest I have not had a chance
to talk to representative Cushing about
the specific rationale for the ten
thousand dollars I do know that over the
last few years there have been uh
several attempts made
to expand uh the scope of the law so for
instance during the session last week
one of the bills that we actually passed
was a bill that actually would open up
the compensation fund to victims of
human trafficking it still has to go to
the Senate and I believe in 2019 we also
looked at the issue of the maximum the
maximum amount
I think the idea behind it is that a lot
of the a lot of the victims of some of
these crimes especially the the sexual
and the violent crimes
there's an impact on their lives that
lasts a long time there's a lot of
psychological healing that needs to
happen and there are also Economic
Consequences of being damaged by crimes
like that so it's hard to go out and
work every day when you've had something
like that happen to you and there are
some people
who can't who have a great deal of
difficulty doing it so I think part of
the um you know part of what we're
trying to do with this fund
um is to make sure that there's a part
of the Criminal Justice System that's
there not just for people who are
accused of crimes but people who are
also victims of crime
other questions
yes representative De Lorenzo
thank you Mr Sherman and thank you Mr
Muse for taking my question
um could you please tell me why the
frm Recovery Fund is included in this
bill
again without having spoken to
representative Cushing it it I I'm not a
hundred percent clear on uh on the whys
and the motivations and things things
like that
as as I see it one of the the primary
reasons is if there are monies that are
left over after the uh the compensation
fund has had a chance to run its course
those monies would go into the the back
into the general victims compensation
fund so I think that's one of the things
that the bill achieves
and uh
and I think
other than that that's the the rationale
that I took away when I saw the bill
representative Lorenzo you'd like to
follow up follow up thank you
um
I am concerned
that the frm money comes out of the
state budget and
I have concerns about that I know it's
been signed into lar but um
I just want to register my concern that
I don't think it's appropriate for
money from the state budget
to have funded uh the frm victims
Recovery Fund because
those folks made a funny they made a
Financial Risk by investing
and they were victims of a Ponzi scheme
but um I'm just not comfortable with
that aspect of this Bill thank you
questions
thank you very much Mr chair and um
like my question would probably better
be addressed to representative walls or
Cushing if they're here but um and
actually first I had to make a
preparatory comment I actually do have a
bill that's in Ways and Means which also
addresses the frm fund issue the
what my bill does is basically just
uh just sunsets as of a 2023 rather than
2024 and puts all the funds back in the
general fund but that's uh that's a
matter
I can go into that more in the executive
session so my question for you
representative Muse is um
does this bill have the effect of does
that cap that's in the section two so
that would apply to the frm victims like
any other victim so they would
henceforce only be entitled to no more
than 40 or 50 000 rather and I'm sure
most of them rather than whatever amount
it damages they're claiming on their
applications
that is my understanding the bill also
would limit
recovery assistance to 50 cents on the
dollar for per actual damage
so what it would do effectively would it
would it would make
um
a higher volume of claimants be eligible
for payment without necessarily having a
couple of people who suffered extremely
large losses kind of running the table
before every everyone else had a chance
to get compensated
so my understanding is that is also what
this bill would achieve okay thanks I
think I understand it better now thanks
representative Chase
Sharon thank you for taking my question
I just want to make sure I understand
this so say a victim not not the fmr do
they have to submit
receipts and who do they go to and who
actually
is watching or overseeing the funding
and getting people reimbursed and then
how do you know there's more money that
was given out and that gets back put
back into the fund does that make sense
is there a like a lump sum that is for
every victim they put their receipts in
and then if they don't qual get all that
money back then it goes back into the
fund
yes I I'm not I'm not 100 sure exactly
how the fund is is uh is administered I
believe the Attorney General's office
administers it um
okay but what process they use to
determine uh who is eligible and uh the
process they use to determine the amount
of compensation
is probably something you would need to
ask them
thank you for saying that clearer than I
did
thank you
are there other questions for
representative Muse
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and if you would fill out a pink card
and some people do that thank you
appreciated
you indicated that representative walls
is on her way do you know what her
status is at all
I do not
um I had my text messages off so okay
she may have tried to message me
thank you is there anyone else who here
who would like to testify on House Bill
I would note that this is our only bill
which is designated to go to a second
committee
criminal justice no I finance I suspect
uh
what I'm going to do at this point in
time is recess the hearing and
but I will close the hearing at have
passed if no one else shows up to
testify
we're going to come out of recess on
House Bill 1235
reconvene the hearing
and call upon
representative Walsh to provide her
testimony
first of all let me apologize for being
late I have agreed to be the permanent
sub for Mel Miler on education and we
were involved in a hearing and I just
lost track of time so I apologize just
I've taken on probably more than I
should
um obviously I was not here for
representative Muse's testimony so I'm
not sure exactly what he said
um I'm presuming he introduced the bill
we spoke last night so I had some ideas
to what he was going to talk about but
what I would like to talk about is two
things one is is that the need to raise
the threshold for the payment to victims
of crime from forty thousand to fifty
thousand
and that stems from the fact that the
cost of everything goes up including the
cost of the damage to the victims and
fifty thousand dollars frankly is still
a pretty modest number for a lot of the
costs associated with people who are
victimized by all kinds of crimes and I
think we as a legislator need to
recognize that their losses increased
just as the cost of everything in our
lives increases
um more
um obtuse in the bill is the Tie to the
frm situation and
um honestly I had nothing to do to draft
this bill but I understand the
representing of Cushing's thoughts
behind it
um he has spoken to me for years talking
about the fact that there really was no
need to do a separate fund for the frm
investors that we had this way for
victims of crime to recover through the
fund which is then outside the
traditional budget it's funded I Believe
by fees and
um that they if they really had a loss
they should have gone through that
particular fund so I believe his attempt
to tie the frm fund back to the victims
of crime fund is because
the frm investors are a victim of crime
and that in this state is the
appropriate way to recover when you are
a victim of crime and that that really
would have been the more appropriate way
for them to seek
um
reimbursement for their losses
understanding that their losses would
far exceed forty thousand dollars but
nevertheless that is the program so my
belief is is that his attempt to tie
what's ever left in that 10 million
dollars that we put in the budget on the
frm fund to this is because this really
is the appropriate venue for victims of
crime to recover their losses
those are really the two points I wanted
to talk about um uh sadly and not to my
liking I seem to know an awful lot about
frm I've been involved in it for a long
time so to the extent you've got
questions about that I have a pretty
good idea of what's going on there or
what has gone on they're more
appropriately but I'll take any
questions that you may have
representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um regarding the victims of the frm
crime Could you
um
enlighten me as to the criminal charges
and what happened uh was uh was someone
found guilty of some particular charge
uh there were there's at least one
person sitting in prison to this day
honestly representative Sylvia I was
focused more on the
um
their attempts at coming back to the
legislature to seek money from the
legislature then at the criminal side of
it but yes people were charged and
convicted and as far as I know are still
in prison for that and it was
substantial I've I know that there were
allegations that it was an 80 million
dollar loss I mean that is really
substantial it's an awful lot of money
and there were people that personally
lost a lot of money I know at least I
think one member of this legislature
lost two million dollars in that crime
um so yes somebody is paying but I just
want to say there are really two
parallel things you need to consider
here one is the criminal case which is
what you asked me about but really the
other issue is the civil case and the
Civil issues and that's honestly more
what I'm familiar with of what happened
in the bankruptcy court Superior Court
and the state supreme court
other questions
I I had a question because I I read the
bill prior to today and
and the part with regard to frm
and
the testimony we heard earlier from
representative Muse was that this now
applied the fifty thousand dollar cap to
the frm
legislation
but as I looked at the legislation it
appeared to me that the only thing it
really did this bill did was say that
instead of the unused frm funds going to
the general fund they now would go to
the
Victim Assistance fund
I believe that is representative
Cushing's goal yes
that fund tends to run out of money so I
think the attempt was to if we've got
this pool of money that we are going to
use for some victims of crime we should
be using it for all victims of crime
and so I guess the question is do you
is the intent of the legislation to
restrict the frm victims to fifty
thousand dollars
um
as the person who didn't draft that it's
really I know I signed it but as the
person who didn't draft that is really
hard for me to
um say what the intent was
um my initial intent was to make sure
that the victims of crime could recover
more money that was really what what I
wanted to do in signing on to this bill
other questions
representative walls thank you and and I
apologize again for being late this is
what happens when I'm serving on two
major committees at the same time as you
get focused on one thing and forget
about another if you haven't already
submitted a pink card would you do that
before you leave thank you I just
grabbed one thank you thank you thank
you for your testimony
again is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 1235
seeing none we will close the hearing
12 35.
we'll call the committee back to order
and begin our hearing open the hearing
on House Bill 1435 relative to the right
of a victim of domestic violence to have
a support person present when testifying
or being deposed
and we will call upon the prime sponsor
representative gay to provide her
testimony here today
no you need to turn on your microphone
thank you
yes this
I'm sorry I've
I've really haven't
a couple years and so I'm not sure of
the protocol but I sent you all the
amended version and now hopefully you
have the paper copy in hand it was
pointed out to me by another attorney
that it was better to make it General
and not not just pointed to protect
victims of domestic abuse for one thing
they may be in a court hearing to prove
that they're victims of domestic abuse
so this is the level the playing field
and let everybody
everybody have that right to have
someone with them when they testify we
know it's usually a pretty
nerve-wracking experience for people and
usually somebody would however in some
cases
the presiding judge told the uh the the
victim but it could just be any
participant that they could not bring
somebody in they could only bring in an
attorney well if they can't afford an
attorney that meant they were there by
themselves so this is just to uh
restore the right for somebody to have
someone with them not to testify just to
be with them
you will have a chance to hear a
counselor who
went through this with a
patient
who was such a victim of DV that they
had PTSD
and could not testify because they were
so fearful and so the perpetrator got
away free because there was no testimony
direct testimony against him
so with that I guess you can ask me
questions if
representative naughter thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking the question does the law
currently prohibit a victim of DV from
having someone there to support them the
law apparently doesn't address it
because it was the judge's opinion
or as ruling that this victim could not
have anybody with her unless it was an
attorney
that doesn't mean it's in statute it's
just there's no protection in statute
representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
this
says that the support person shall not
be restricted
um by the presiding judge and if this is
not an attorney
that seems like that opens up
the court to perhaps some rashed
Behavior which the judge would not be
able to control
could you address that concern yes
that's a different interpretation of
what the intention is and so if you want
to amend it so that it's more clear
the the intention was that the judge
could not set aside the right for the
person to have someone with them it
didn't mean that the person could do
anything they wanted to do
so if you want to change those words you
know it's fine with me because that's
what it meant
other questions
okay I do have a question then and you
mentioned that
it's not uncommon for people
particularly in domestic violence cases
to have a support person with them
but the support person does not speak
and when you testified you said that
this person because of PTSD was unable
to speak at court is it your intention
that the support person
would actually be representing and
speaking on behalf of people
thank you for your question again
as Dr Wittgenstein from the 1800s
somewhere said the porosity of language
allows a whole lot of interpretation to
go through the same web of words no this
is just a support person to be present
again if you want to
make an amendment that I'm totally
supportive of clarifying the intention
it's just half the person there not to
testify unless you know unless
in an if they're in a trial you know we
would hope that they would want to but
that has nothing to do with the
intention of this bill
just presence
other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
representative thank you
and I have a card from representative
homila
okay and who would you do that it's Dr
Rhonda Hodge
okay Dr Hodge
hi hi so my name is Dr Rhonda Hodge and
I own Harmony Psychiatric Services in
Salem New Hampshire board certified in
primary care and board certified and
Psychiatry I have just under two decades
of experience in mental health
and some of the work that Betty's been
doing has been pretty incredible and
aggressive and necessary so for this
bill in particular one of the reasons
that I'm here to speak is to give a
little bit of background but also to
tell you one story that's gonna
I think in some of the stories that we
have it's going to seem as if they
couldn't actually be happening and
they're not actually real
um I have a lot of patients just be by
the nature of my work whether it's
through patients or friends or friends
of friends of friends especially during
the pandemic that have come forward with
situations like this
I went through with this one particular
patient based on
the abuser's job he is somebody that's
not in power as far as
this type of power but it still would be
considered a power position we went to
the attorney general we went to
um
Rockingham I ended up bringing this
particular person to the County
prosecutor and they really were super
helpful the biggest problem was this
young lady had was pregnant and she also
had a child
um and she was petrified of this
particular person
um we also know that he had and this is
very common too he had GPS on her phone
as well as something where he could hear
it during our sessions we I would have
to put her phone outside of um into a
different room so that he would not be
able to hear her and this is way more
common than you think
um for example like apple right now has
something if you lose your phone or
whatever you can stick that right on
someone's car and you can track them
um so knowing that you can he actually
would know where she was right so we
were at the prosecutor the excuse me the
county attorney
a County prosecutor and I had to stay
outside while she was being interviewed
which makes sense again everybody was
supportive everybody was loving
everybody was ready to listen but they
also have a job to do I was unable to
stay in there with her
we started the interview and I was able
to sit next to her just for her to do
the basic introduction and before she
did her full deposition I was then asked
I had to leave because that's what you
have to do because if you can't if she
couldn't sit in front of a judge if this
went to trial
then she wasn't nothing like nothing was
going to happen right because if they it
wouldn't be a strong case
I waited outside and this was during the
pandemic
so there wasn't really anyone there so I
waited outside and it must have been an
hour and a half two hours they tried and
she couldn't stop shaking she couldn't
stop crying she was scared if he was
going to come through the door she was
scared because she also had to leave her
child with somebody else
I mean the evidence that we actually had
was so strong other than her not being
able to speak we had text messages we
had pictures we had
um medical records not just mine and she
had never really come forward to speak
and we kind of put it all together to
hand it over but she was petrified to do
this
needless to say he did find out what she
had done there was no case
he's still in a position of somewhat
power
and she wasn't able to keep herself in
her kiddo safe
things did happen after and but nothing
I mean they are still they they are
doing somewhat well at this point but
without me being there I offered to you
know turn around and just hold her hand
since being there she felt
safe with me which is why she opened up
to me to begin with and so me being
there for her she probably wouldn't
would have been able to speak and she
begged for it but they couldn't allow it
because then they'd have to bring
something in front of a judge for trial
and if she wasn't able to do that
without me being there than there was
going to be no case I think that's
really has to do with the understanding
of what domestic violence does to a
victim and you know we know about PTSD
and we know about those isolated
incidents with you know for example rape
or someone who had a near-death
experience
cptsd is what domestic violence victims
have so if you're putting them in front
of people who have who are considered in
power for them they're feeling really
their brain that says like fight or
flight
like I'm in danger and it's they can't
shut that off
so to not have somebody with them you're
you're it's never you're never going to
get the results in order to keep these
people safe and we see it happening I
mean we see it happening nationally but
we definitely see it happening in this
state all the time the stories that I
hear and the stories I mean as a
provider now in the state of New
Hampshire I'm honestly I when I have
people coming to me I don't know whether
or not to tell them to go forward or to
tell them not to go forward I don't know
that they're going to be kept safe and
if they don't have somebody with them
and they can't even speak how am I as a
provider supposed to say no we're going
to keep you safe
we can't
they don't even have a voice while it's
still like while their voice is kind of
still shaking and they haven't found
that strength
so I I fully support this
um
people should be able to have somebody
with them and somebody that they feel
safe with
speaking I mean it's easier for it's
easy for me to speak to you but imagine
that I'm a victim and I'm sitting here
in front of this table this is exactly
what it looks like
so
questions for Dr Hodge yes
representative nodder thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question but I have a comment first
um I have been the support person for
someone who went through a similar
situation and I didn't speak I was just
there you said some initials and I don't
think I wrote them down correctly could
you repeat them was it c p s t cptsd so
it's complex PTSD and what it means is
the difference between PTSD and complex
PTSD is complex PS PTSD excuse me is
continuously happening so whereas PTSD
you're looking at an isolated incident
someone who's in an abusive situation if
you assume like you're come every time
your abuser comes in the door you have
to have yourself ready to know you don't
know who's walking through the door it's
continuous abuse continuous traumatic
situations so it's not just not that
it's just because I don't take anything
away from PTSD at all and and what it
does but the complex PTS it means it's a
continuation of things happening
throughout a period of time
it's representative otter um follow-up
so PTSD can come at any time like a
flashback but complex it never goes away
there's constant height and fear is that
correct if you're not removed from the
situation uh then it's it's pretty
continuous it's not that it it doesn't
it's similar to PTSD and the way that
you will have triggers you can go right
back to that within within seconds with
cptsd it's
if you are in PTSD and you have a
situation where you were somewhere and
you know the place you know where you're
at you know who the person was with CPS
PTSD excuse me it can happen throughout
the person's entire life so their entire
life doesn't feel safe so if they're in
an abusive situation they don't know
when their abuser is going to whether
it's home whether they're at work
whether they're getting constant calls
whether they're being stalked whether
they're leaving their child I mean it's
so continuous it goes throughout their
entire life
whereas if it's one circumstance it's a
little bit easier to work with
other questions yes representative Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so would you be
actually sitting
like this like you're saying as a person
is testifying and then what if when they
go to court would you be sitting
actually in the witness stand would you
have to be sworn in as well how does
that work I would say and I think that
kind of goes back to the comment you
were making so that doesn't become an
erratic environment I that would be
something that I would think would make
the most sense is that the per the
support person be under the same oath as
the person they're sitting next to
okay thank you one follow-up so then you
would actually be sitting with the
victim not out where they can see you
and have eye contact is this is what
we're trying to do you know I would ask
Betty for the specifics of that I mean
it would be it honestly was the best
recommendation to have especially if I'm
thinking of the the people that I've
worked with it
having somebody out there so if you're
sitting sitting it sitting in the box
and your support person's right in front
of you that's great but so is the
attorney so is your abusers you know the
so to have I if if that support person
doesn't get in the courtroom and
typically I'll tell people to kind of
make sure they sit back and lean over so
that they don't necessarily have eye
contact with their abuser
um but if they don't get that right spot
in the courtroom that adds a whole other
layer to it
I would recommend that somebody is able
to sit adjacent to them
um I don't know if that fully changes
things thank you
other questions representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um we had a similar Bill to this a
couple years ago regarding um
miners caught in a domestic abuse and
the ability to have a therapy animal
um with them at the host stand and I
think the concern or not the host and
the the where they're testifying
um and I think the concern that we had
before was about the perceived the
perception of the jury to have an animal
or another person at the witness stand
alongside the victim or perceived
alleged victim
um in the the perception that the jury
would have having somebody like yourself
up there with the alleged victim so I
guess can you kind of shed some light on
that absolutely so the difference would
be is that you're either going to get a
testimony or you're not is really what's
going to happen for most people they
will it won't they won't even
necessarily answer the questions
correctly Their Fear in that spidey
sense I told you is going to take over
so if you have that support person with
them and they have again you feel they
feel safe with you then
you're going to be more likely to get
an appropriate testimony so a lot of
times when somebody is on the stand and
they're by themselves not only are they
trying to not only are they in fight or
flight they are also in a situation
where they are um
they're scared right so if it doesn't
follow through this person in front of
them is now it's it's open so the
they're they're going to be scared about
that so they're going to be calculated
in the fact that I'm as far as like I'm
I'm too scared they're not able to think
clearly they're not able to even answer
the questions they're not able to do
things in a timeline because they're
panicking and a lot of times that's what
ends up happening honestly and there's
been some research recent studies that
um women of course abuse happens to
um all both genders but women are 60
more likely to lose custody of their
children if they say that there's been
domestic abuse
um so with that there's I think she I
think Betty used the word hysteria
that's really what is happening you're
you're putting people in the situation
where
they can't even think
so to ask them to testify and answer
questions is pretty tough
thank you any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
doctor
representative hamilla we should testify
yes sir thank you for giving me this
opportunity I'm representative mola and
I am testifying in support it's okay I
always my name's always said homila I'm
here to support this bill and the
amendment
um
one of the things that I was yesterday I
was in children and family listening to
testimony and in that I saw there was a
bill on 50 50 parenting and some parents
who are experiencing issues with the
family court system came in to testify
the level of
the level of intimidation they felt in
this warm comfortable setting was was
Stark and at one point one of the people
that were there they were providing
testimony they were very upset they've
had an awful experience and they could
not get through their testimony until
somebody came and sat next to them and
they just had to be there
um
when people are experiencing domestic
violence we all know this it's it's just
a very intimidating process I less than
a year ago I was in a guest in a hotel
walking down the hallway the door is
open the maid cart was outside and
somebody was crying inside I used to be
a maid in college so I went right on in
to make sure she was she or he was okay
she was crying and I asked her if she
was all right and she was holding her
phone in her hand and she was telling me
my husband just got out of jail
we have a restraining order he knows
where the kids live
and she didn't know what to do in that
moment she was trying to figure out how
is she going to get her kids safe we all
know that this doesn't apply just to
women when I was stationed in the Air
Force I actually worked with a gentleman
who was getting abused by his wife
here is a very medium-sized guy who
could have defended himself in any
instance but on one particular instance
his male
supervisor who is all of five foot and a
half inch had a step in the middle of
that situation because he could not he
could not function he was so intimidated
so we already know that those situations
are highly charged behind closed doors
now you take these individuals and you
bring them in a public courtroom and ask
them as they must to face the people
that they're accusing of abuse
it's a very very intimidating process I
support this bill because I think this
is the a small but very critical step we
can do to help people provide effective
testimony thank you
excuse me any questions
yes representative Chase thank you I'm
sorry why are you eliminated just to
domestic violence what
I mean I I understand that I think it's
great but there are other things that
are traumatic as well would you maybe
add on to this if it passes
um when I first was considering and was
requested to consider the bill you know
I was looking at it through the lens of
domestic violence but that's a very good
point and I'm sure that I'm sure the
representative gay would be open to any
any additional things that can provide
provide additional protections to other
other people in the same boat thank you
thank you
I would note that the amendment that
representative gay provided us with
today indicates it would be for any
family court proceeding
any other questions thank you
representative thank you sir
we have two more people who are signed
up to testify on the bill uh the next
one is Lynn sholette
good morning good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is Lynn
Chalet and I'm the executive director of
the New Hampshire Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence
we are I'm gonna have to take this one
off we are the umbrella Organization for
the 12 community-based crisis centers in
New Hampshire that provide free and
confidential services to victims of
Domestic and Sexual Violence all
throughout New Hampshire we serve
approximately fifteen thousand victims
every year
we greatly appreciate the intention of
the sponsor that victims of domestic
violence have support in court cases and
I want to thank the Doctor Who so
eloquently talked about how difficult it
is for victims to be in court around the
domestic violence they've experienced
that being said we have two specific
concerns about how this bill addresses
this
first of all we do have protocols in New
Hampshire we have extensive protocols
that were created from a
multi-disciplinary task force and are
housed within the judicial branch that
already allow a victim of domestic
violence to have an advocate in their
court case in their hearings
second of all it is unclear to us why
this amendment would be placed in 173b
under the domestic violence protection
order statute when the bill itself
references family law cases
so I'd like to take just a minute to
share with you what the protocols that I
referenced do cover and talk about
these Protocols are comprehensive and
they reference Advocates over 30 times
they outline not only where and how an
advocate should be available but how an
advocate can focus on the safety of a
victim during a court process so I'll
just share with you three specific
sections that reference the role of
advocates in these cases in the protocol
section 5-14 it provides that when a
hearing is conducted quote any Advocate
assisting the plaintiff shall be allowed
to accompany the plaintiff in the
courtroom or in Chambers
in protocol section 5-25 the the
protocol provides that the court should
quote make available the phone number of
the local crisis center and the
opportunity to have a court Advocate
present during the final hearing and
quote furthermore courts should advise
and refer plaintiffs to local crisis
centers if an advocate is not already
present for safety planning which is so
important in addition to providing
support in the actual Court proceeding
one third example I'll share is protocol
section 7-7 which provides that if a
plaintiff is accompanied by an advocate
The Advocate should be allowed at
Council table
and may be allowed limited participation
in the proceeding at the request of the
plaintiff to so so to several of the
questions you asked this morning there
are already very specific guidelines for
The Advocates who are permitted to be
present and be in the courtroom
I think what's important about these
examples is they illustrate the clear
intention of the Courts for domestic
violence victims to have an advocate
present before during and after their
hearings
and specifically there are two benefits
to having trained Advocates working with
victims one is the underlying training
Advocates are trained on not just the
Dynamics of Domestic and Sexual Violence
which you heard about this morning but
also about the court process itself
the second reason is that we have a
statute in New Hampshire that protects
the confidentiality of communications
between victims and those Advocates a
concern I would have about the example
that was shared with you this morning is
that someone like a physician or an
untrained support person could then be
called as a witness in the case that
would be so detrimental to the victim
whereas Advocates who are trained at
crisis centers are protected
in their confidential relationship with
those victims
these domestic violence protocols were
intentionally created with an emphasis
and a focus on safety planning so the
training The Advocates have is not just
about the support in the courtroom but
also to work with the victim after a
hearing to ensure that they're safe
because what we know is when a victim is
finally able to go to court that is one
of the most lethal and dangerous times
so to have someone with you who has the
expertise to help you plan for your
safety after the hearing is critical
lastly as I mentioned from a drafting
perspective we have concerns about where
this is being put into the code the bill
itself references family law cases but
it's actually an amendment to the
protective order statute which is
already very clear about the role of
Advocates and and the support that they
can provide to victims so we strongly
encourage the committee to vote itl on
this bill again we are hugely supportive
of the opportunity for victims to have a
support person but we think that that
should be done through trained Advocates
throughout the state of New Hampshire
thank you so much I'm happy to take any
questions questions yes represent Kenny
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for taking my question
um so you just laid out the protocols
that New Hampshire already has for a
support person
um but
can currently a judge disregard those
protocols and say no the judge should
not disregard them and so I'm not
familiar with this single underlying
case that representative gay was
speaking about but we work
collaboratively with the courts on a
regular basis to ensure that judges
receive training and are using those
protocols and the judicial branch has
absolutely endorsed them and made very
clear through a supreme court order that
they should be followed thank you so
much
representative Nader
so I have two questions the the first
one is when does a victim get to meet
the trained Advocate and the second one
is that how long does it take for a
victim to learn to grow trust
the stranger who's the trained advocate
so a victim can reach out for an
advocate anytime they want to or need to
in fact anyone in New Hampshire who
needs support or information or guidance
around sexual or domestic violence can
call our 24-hour hotline every day of
the year so a victim may have just been
sexually assaulted may have just been
battered maybe thinking about going to
the hospital maybe considering reporting
to police they can connect with an
advocate 24 hours a day it does they
don't have to wait until a court process
begins Advocates are available in every
community in New Hampshire around the
clock so often what happens is a victim
has worked with an advocate quite a
while before they are actually in the
court proceeding
other questions
yep representative wolper thank you Mr
Mr chairman uh my question is for you
and for all those who have testified and
that it would be do you have written
testimony that you're submitting to this
committee we do and we sent it to you
this morning around 10 15. thank you for
asking representative yeah I just it's a
lot easier for us if we know that exists
and I'm supposed to record that so and I
was probably supposed to say that so
thank you for prompting me
I had a a couple of things and and the
way
this is currently written it says that
any party could have a support person
so
that would indicate that not just
petitioners and domestic violence could
have a petition a support person but
a
abuser could have a support person there
and so
is that currently the circumstance as
far as you know it
I don't think the protocol addresses
that issue specifically I mean
defendants usually frequently are
represented by Council and again we have
some confusion here about whether we're
talking about family law cases or
protective order cases
um but I don't think that's addressed in
the protocol and I think the intent of
the protocols is really to ensure that
if parties are not whether or not
they're represented by Council that they
have a trained support person with them
and as a follow-up to that they and I
think you'd just address that the issue
is having someone who is trained the
doctors here the doctor obviously has
some training and some background but
the way this is written anybody
it appears that anybody could be a
support person not necessarily someone
who is trained you could you could
potentially have your beer buddy be your
support person if that's what you wanted
thank you representative that's true and
I think
um what all of the testimony today has
highlighted is a courtroom is a foreign
place for a victim they have already
experienced so much trauma and it is
most helpful to victims to have someone
supporting them through the process who
works in the court system routinely who
knows how the process works who knows
how the clerk's office Works who can
explain to victims what to expect when a
judge takes a ruling under advisement
for example in a protective order case
so that training is really critical to
the service and support that the victim
would receive
if I could one last question because
this this intrigues me and that's the
issue about being present during a
deposition and to what extent currently
are your advocates
involved in
depositions my understanding is that
it's less frequent for victims to have
any support person present with them in
depositions because one of the risks
that you run is they just become so
involved in the case and could become
Witnesses so I don't think that's
happening very much in general but I'm
happy to follow up with you if it if I
learn that that's different happy to
consult with our colleagues at New
Hampshire legal assistance
thank you
any other questions
representative di Lorenzo thank you Mr
chairman I just have a question of um
Charlotte
um
looking at this bill you wreck you
recommended itl I'm sorry you
recommended itl
is there any way we can save this bill
I thank you for your question
representative I don't think so because
I don't think the Avenue for supporting
victims is to open the door so widely to
people who do not have necessarily the
training or background both in trauma
and in the court system thank you thank
you
representative otter thank you Mr
chairman I don't know if I can how to
word this correctly but
if someone's a victim of domestic
violence I don't know I don't know if
that I believe that they actually need
somebody trained a stranger I think just
having someone they trust with them is
is what will give them the confidence to
speak
so I you know I think what I would say
to that is I I hope that an advocate
would not be a stranger to the victim
first of all it's not someone who just
shows up on the day of the hearing this
is the person they have met with to get
oriented to the court process perhaps to
review the forms together to prepare for
the court hearing so it's not someone
new just showing up at the hearing
um and certainly having an advocate
doesn't take away from the fact that we
encourage all victims to have an
extensive support system and people
could still come and sit in the gallery
during a hearing but the protocol
specifically provide for an advocate as
you heard who could be at Council table
and I think for that person we do want
someone as you all pointed out in your
questions earlier who's familiar with
the court process who would understand
what the judge's expectations are around
courtroom decorum and responses so for
that particular role I do I respectfully
disagree and think the training is
important
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you so much
and the last witness submitting a card
is Richard head
aches
I'm up okay
um good morning my name is Richard head
I'm the government and Affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch I do
not have written testimony I'm here to
provide information
um on the bill we do not have a specific
position on the bill as you heard from
the past the last speaker there are
domestic violence protocols I won't
repeat that but those are utilized by
the judges and that's the process
they're they're following in the
domestic violence cases I do want to
point out there is
um uh currently a domestic violence task
force that is under that is underway the
Chief Justice set it up the end of last
year they had their first meeting
yesterday and those meetings are going
on
it is a an important
vehicle for any suggestions relative to
legislation dealing with domestic
violence because at those task force
meetings are a wide range of of people
with different backgrounds different
expertise and can bring to a particular
issue a breadth of knowledge and
experience that is is very important
when trying to vet these types of very
important issues so anyone who has a
specific
thoughts or or suggestions relative to
domestic violence protocols domestic
violence process or or anything in this
Arena I would urge you to and anybody to
uh to reach out to a member of that
commission
um and talk to them about any specific
issues that that you may have on the
Court's website is a link to the to the
task forces website their meetings are
being streamed their meetings are being
recorded and available on the on the
task Force's website so it is an
important mechanism and I expect that
coming out of that task force will be
legislative recommendations I would be
surprised if they are not so that is an
important vehicle I think for ideas such
as this to be vetted to be vetted in a
in a in a public forum but also with
people who have a diverse back who have
diverse backgrounds and can bring that
that type of information and knowledge
to these types of issue use so I think
it's also so for for information that's
a it's an important process that is
going on now and the expectation is
they're going to be issuing a report
probably in March or April of this year
um I also note that the amendment I
think there are questions about it
earlier uh talks about
um the the person who would be present
would not be subject to any restrictions
by the trial judge and that is
concerning that does create potential
problems both in terms of due process in
terms of the management of the courtroom
and how and and to ensure that the
rights of all of the parties are
respected and followed so I think that
type of of openness is significantly
problematic in terms of a trial judge's
Authority and and obligation to maintain
order in a courtroom
um with also regard to the the amendment
um it is it is undefined in terms of who
the support person would be as you heard
in earlier testimony there is a system
where uh where domestic violence
Advocates do have the right to be
present with the victim at Council table
and throughout the proceeding if
somebody arrives at the courthouse
without any domestic violence advocate
in their in their background or
presently using utilizing one clerks do
inform uh the people as they're coming
up to the window to file about the
services what's available it's a very
important part of that that transaction
if if the domestic violence victim is
interacting with the clerk's office so
that knowledge and information is
provided at the court but they're
typically as you heard before they're
coming to the court already with an
advocate with them and those Advocates
are trained and the court process is
incredibly important and that training
is incredibly important because
misinformation can be equally damaging
in terms of ensuring that the process is
followed and ensuring that the that the
parties to these proceedings are getting
accurate information about the
proceeding to ensure that their rights
are also being that their rights are are
being properly represented without a I'm
sorry one one last thought in terms of
access to to support people in a
courtroom there is sort of a separate
body of law that deals with Americans
with Disabilities if there is a person
who is unable to obtain access to court
proceedings because of a disability that
includes mental health issues it
includes physical disabilities includes
a whole host of potential issues those
are and we do see those addressed
through motions to the court depending
on the type of accommodation that is
being requested but accommodations
outside of of the state statute but
within the context of the Americans with
Disabilities do apply and there can be
very specific instances where an
accommodation is granted because of a
disability that is that is raised to the
judge raised in a timely way in which
the the judge is then able to to proceed
with that but that also comes with sort
of a burden to make sure that the the
issues are presented to the court the
information is is is accurate and the
accommodation is is requested
and with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr chairman are
there any questions
representative De Lorenzo
uh for a person who has a disability at
what point in the case
would the
victim file for reasonable accommodation
would that be with an answer or
something like that so the thank you for
the question the the issue of when the
reasonable accommodation is provided is
is really there are actually two ways it
can be raised one is whether or not it
has a direct impact on the case whether
you know it be the setup of the
courtroom sometimes is important the the
density of people that's in the
courtroom can be important the uh the
presence of of a support person may be
at issue in in terms of the
accommodation but it has to be raised so
if it is uh if it relates to sort of the
Court proceeding it would have to be
raised before the hearing occurs because
the court then needs to you know
evaluate the accommodation requested
ensure that it's available and to ensure
that it does not otherwise impact the
proceeding in a negative way so not all
accommodations are going to be granted
if the accommodation requested is going
to adversely impact the case
if it's not sort of a procedure case
specific issue those are handled more at
the administrative office of the courts
so those are examples of needing
interpreters needing
somebody who can do sign language
somebody who has difficulty with uh with
reading there may be other
accommodations that are not specific to
a case but in order to provide that
person with access typically language is
the most common those are requested
before the proceeding to ensure that an
interpreter with the right skills is
present for the for the proceeding
are there any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you and our Final witness
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Walt Stapleton I am
the
Claremont Third Ward representative
Sullivan County District Five and I I
come before you in support
of this bill
um and I I take with great interest the
the commentaries
um and the testimonies that have
proceeded relative to The Advocates
protocols and that's really good news
um
and uh to know that the court has
reasonable accommodations and Advocate
protocols
is comforting however
there's a personal aspect
of people who have been abused
are in a syndrome
and it's difficult for them to speak
in public
and in court forum
and and other places where they have to
address what's been done to them
and I'm focusing on the personal aspect
of this Advocates are fine if they're
available
and I've heard that they're not always
and The Advocate is well trained as they
might be
is not a known person
now there is the possibility when The
Advocate and the
um plaintiff meat that they click and
there's a immediate confidence but we
know human nature varies so it could be
the opposite
the value
of a known person entity
as a support person and if not at the
council table
somewhere in the room where eye contact
could be made and The Advocate
can call upon that person to come to
Plaintiff in order to be able to elicit
the testimony
seems like it shouldn't be an either or
but how about a combination of both
and maybe under reasonable accommodation
an advocate assigned could also enlist
the support of that support person in in
the in case there is a difficult moment
and the testimony stops because of the
the plaintiff's discomfort and stress
so I would say that this law doesn't
challenge anything that's already there
but actually edifies what the court has
made
and the protocols are in effect
so I would encourage the committee to
support and move this bill forward thank
you very much
are there any questions for
representative Stapleton
yes representative Kenny thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so
um I believe you said that under our
current procedures that sometimes
Advocates are unavailable so are there
situations where
um plaintiffs have requested Advocates
and then have not been able to be given
one
that's what I've heard I do not have
personal knowledge of these situations I
did not do not operate in that
particular venue so I can't answer your
question okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
and
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on 1435
seeing Nolan we will close the hearing
on House Bill 1435.
typically no
I think we're going to close the hearing
at this point in time okay okay and she
what she should do is submit written
testimony as she wishes to do that and
we will consider that testimony before
we make our decision
by email would be perfect
just to the house Judiciary Committee
okay the hearing on 1435 is closed
and we will move on to our next hearing
this morning
and our final hearing for the morning
which is house bill 1101.
and we have several speakers today
and rep I'm I'm here I'm filling in
you're filling in yes
so uh we'll call upon representative
naughter who I understand is filling in
for the prime sponsor representative
Sylvia today yes um
for the record I rep
one and I'm here to introduce House Bill
1101 for representative Silva the rep
Sylvia relative to a forfeiture of
personal property and I will refer all
testimony to those uh on the pink cards
thank you for your brief testimony
okay the first person to be called upon
was be Dan McGuire
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire and I'm from
Epsom I was a State Rep when we started
um
uh improving the asset forfeiture area
of state law maybe eight years ago
something like that and
um so this bill we we've been doing it
over the years in in Little Steps and
this bill is yet another uh little step
unfortunately there are there are three
bills
um relating to asset forfeiture that are
being heard at this very moment this one
and two next door in criminal justice
that's why you're going to see people
shuttling back and forth I'm sorry to
say
but what this bill does is
um so asset forfeiture is the the
process of when there are there's
property used in the commission of a
crime or that is the result of a crime
um typically we're talking about drug
crimes so it could be
a vehicle used as part of selling drugs
it could be property used it could be
cash that's a result of selling drugs
that kind of thing so that property can
be seized by police officers and and
um forfeited and under state law we have
what's called criminal forfeiture which
means that we now have we didn't
originally but we now have criminal
forfeiture which means that the
perpetrator of the crime has to be
convicted of that crime and then the
property in involved can be forfeited
under
previous state law and under federal law
it's a it's it's almost it's they have
what's called civil forfeiture which
means that there's effectively a
separate case against the car or the
cash or whatever compared to the person
and they could even not charge a person
of a crime but they could still go
forward with a case against the property
and say that the property was involved
in the commission of a crime and the
reason we've we've changed state law to
criminal forfeiture is is twofold one is
that the burden of proof on criminal
cases is is higher you you have to prove
things Beyond a reasonable doubt you
have to provide if in the case that the
the defendant is Indigent you have to
provide an attorney that sort of thing
whereas the case in civil court is just
preponderance of the evidence there is
no attorney provided and so on and so
it's been the feeling of the New
Hampshire legislature that
um forfeiting of property is a
punishment and if somebody is going to
be punished they ought to have been
proven as to be a criminal
um it it can't just be that you punish
somebody but there's no criminal act
been proven so
um so what this particular Bill does
House Bill 1101 is just say to
prosecutors first of all it has no
effect on police officers what they do
and so on they would still arrest people
and seize property and so on just the
same way they do now but it says to
prosecutors
um that you should prosecute people
under New Hampshire law rather than
under federal law you should use our
forfeiture law
and
um in in some cases so so in particular
um
federal law has this concept called
adoption I mean drug crimes typically
drug crimes are both against state law
they're also against federal law and so
a prosecutor has a choice when they
prosecute somebody can they process
which one do they use to prosecute them
and they can go to a federal prosecutor
and say how about taking this case and
and Prosecuting under federal law and so
what this says is that unless the the
the enforcement action was part of a
Joint Task Force between Federal
officers and State uh local officers
those kind of cases could be prosecuted
under federal law but if this was
strictly done if the case was strictly
prosecuted involves local police
officers or state police officers then
you must use state law that's what
that's what this bill changes there
would no longer be the option of of
using federal law okay and so again the
the reason that
prosecutors might choose federal law is
because of the lower burden of proof and
so on
um also
um
there's incentives in federal law for
the local for for police officers
because federal law at the end of the
day takes 80 percent of seized for
forfeited property and returns that to
to
um uh to local officers whereas local
jurisdictions whereas uh state law only
returns 45 percent of forfeited property
to local jurisdictions so there's
different incentives involved
so this is this bill involves is
important in terms of
um principle right so the principle of
requiring a criminal conviction prior to
forfeiture is what's involved here but
it there's not a lot of cases in turn a
lot not a lot of money involved in in
this
um
over the last three years there's been a
total of 18 such cases that would be
affected by this and 75 Joint Task Force
type of cases so that's a very tiny
percentage the amount of money involved
over the last three years has all
forfeited money was a hundred and
seventy two thousand dollars over three
years right so we're talking about sixty
thousand dollars a year worth of
forfeiture
um
that would be affected by this bill and
and that's over the entire state right
so it we're not talking about a lot of
money we are talking about a lot of
principle and I would ask you to pass
this bill
thank you are there questions for Mr
McGuire
yes representative Horrigan
thank you very much Mr Mr chairman thank
you good to see you again representative
McGuire otherwise you're around the
State House more than many people who
are uh members of the uh still members
of the legislature see
so you talk about the incentive to the
police they get 80 percent of the
federal seizures only 45 percent of the
local jurisdictions the other 55 percent
goes to various uh State funds so
why is the why is it where why is it bad
to for them to get 80
um instead of 45 percent
I don't think that's thank you for the
question representative but I don't
think that's the key Point here
um
uh that was a decision already made by
the legislature when they made
uh therefore their forfeiture procedure
um the the key point I'm just saying why
somebody is why officers have an
incentive to want to use federal law but
the key point the reason behind this
bill the ins the the is for fairness
um and the fact that we want to use
state law over the years we've improved
state law we want to make use of state
law it's appropriate
thanks
thank you are there other questions from
Mr McGuire
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you Mr chairman
and uh next person to testify would be
Ross Conley
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for holding his hearing today
for the record my name is Ross Connolly
I'm the deputy state director for
Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire uh here to voice our support
for HB 1101 this bill should be quite
familiar to this committee uh it's
passed here a couple times uh and it's
very similar language uh as before and
and we view this as a a
really an exercise and respecting
federalism
making sure that that law enforcement is
complying with state law while also
giving them the ability to to continue
as as planned with Joint Task forces as
the previous speaker mentioned I don't
want to repeat too much of what he said
but in 2016 this legislature passed the
law which required a conviction before
forfeiture proceedings could begin again
this doesn't affect seizures police can
keep the same protocol they can seize
property they can do continue as as
they're performing now but uh in order
to Forfeit that property the state must
uh have a conviction and that RSA is 617
colon 1-A
and and we view viewed that as a very
critical uh portion to to make sure that
due process is being protected and and
property rights are being respected uh
this bill specifically addresses the
most obvious violation of that current
statute which is the federal adoptions
program under the Equitable sharing uh
program in the Federal Department of
Justice uh as the previous speaker
pointed out
those forfeitures only account for 19 of
all forfeitures in the state over the
past three years uh Joint Task forces
account for 81 which amounts for uh 172
073 dollars over three years Statewide
and uh presuming all of those received
convictions this would really only
affect about twenty five thousand
dollars Statewide uh accounting for that
difference in in the 80 percent uh
return to localities or the forty
percent forty five percent uh return to
localities so uh we view this as as a
very straightforward and modest change
to make sure that that law enforcement
is is complying with with current state
law uh and I'd be happy to take any
questions
questions for Mr Conley
see none I think you're clear thank you
thank you very much for your time
Captain Joe Ebert
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Joe Ebert it is
e-b-e-r-t I'm a captain with the state
police
and I oversee our Investigative Services
Bureau which is our Detectives
I have signed in today in opposition to
this bill and specifically I look at
that paragraph two you've heard an awful
lot of testimony this morning about uh
seizures and adoptions by federal
prosecutors
I think what I took from maybe and
perhaps incorrectly but this was my take
on the testimony that I heard was that
um it seems as though there's a concern
that uh
Federal the federal government is
adopting cases for the sake of the
forfeiture a greater amount of
forfeiture and I would submit to the
committee that there is a number of
reasons why it may be advantageous for
uh a case to be prosecuted at the
federal level as opposed to the state
level
um so we we would certainly oppose this
bill and have concern that the this
there may be a coordination of events to
uh first Force to use the state
forfeiture account and then in in later
iterations of uh legislation to guide
where those funds go and what I would
submit to you is that we we do utilize I
understand the testimony has been it's a
small amount of money we take that money
I talk to our business agent this
morning and said what specifically do we
use this money for we specifically use
it as it is intended to be for law
enforcement enforcement purposes and
almost all of the time it is placed
right back into the cycle of our
narcotics unit so for the purchase of
vehicles for the purchase of body wires
for the purchase of other equipment so I
would submit to you that a small amount
of money what may be a small amount of
money to members of the legislature or
uh or or somebody else is a significant
amount to those of us who are working on
a a very restrictive budget
so having said all that I'm happy to
answer any questions at this time
representative wolper
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
did I understand you to say that your
concern over this bill was where the
money might go
no the uh what I was uh trying to allude
to Sir is uh I've testified uh in a
number of years in the past uh over uh
where the direction of forfeitures may
or may not go and uh and in some cases
have testified to what they may or may
not be used for uh what I was trying to
allude to sir and uh although it's not
germane specific to this bill my
opposition or the division of State
police's opposition is Bill is based on
the notion that we feel like if a
federal prosecutor adopts this case then
we should use the federal forfeiture
program what I was saying was uh we do
look at this in a long-term fashion as
well to say uh is there an effort to
push the forfeitures toward the state
side
um with the eye on those funds for
something to be diverted at a later date
are there other questions
yes representative trottier
thank you Mr speaker thank you sir a
quick question for you on the drug cases
in New Hampshire are a lot of those
turned over to a federal agent to
prosecutor or are they usually done
within state law so I I appreciate the
question
um
a lot is a hard it's a hard term to
quantify but they are adopted in some
instances so an example that I can give
you uh that in talking to our narcotics
unit this morning is that well when does
this happen you explain this to me when
when did these happen I've seen it a
number of times but I never truly
understood like well why does it happen
what may take place is our Troopers may
be out on 95 and they may see two kilos
of cocaine and at some point there is a
discussion with the U.S attorney's
Office where the U.S attorney says this
is a case that we believe is applicable
to federal law and we would like to
prosecute it so that does happen and in
that instance and as it relates to a
paragraph two there is no federal
involvement in the seizure that is
strictly a state police case it is a
state case until such time that the uh
the U.S attorney comes in and says we
want to adopt this and it's our position
that once that happens that we should
follow the Federal uh the federal system
in other words we should go through the
federal forfeiture program if we were in
the state proceedings at that time as I
understand it we stopped that state
proceeding and we now transfer it to the
federal uh proceeding and we follow
those guidelines thank you
one more question
um would it be more common so if all of
a sudden State Police or any
unit that has a drug investigation and
it starts here in New Hampshire and it
goes over state lines would that be a
time that would be turned over to a
federal agency to prosecute I think that
the the federal government certainly
looks at uh factors such as where where
to uh where did this narcotics come from
proximity to the Border but I also think
that they look at the uh the amount of
the seizure the weight of the seizure
and what I would suggest to you is that
uh during these conversations uh they
they certainly happen uh above the the
level of a captain and the state police
but I will tell you that uh I'm I'm
certain that the cases I'm aware of that
have been adopted have been significant
cases and I think that oftentimes that
is when there is a large amount of
Narcotics we find that the U.S
attorney's office is more interested in
taking those cases and putting them
through the federal system adopting them
and putting them through the federal
system okay thank you
one follow-up question so basically it's
the logic cases that the federal agents
will prosecute then smaller that's been
my experience I I can't remember ever uh
and I don't want to say uh with
definitive nature that it can happen but
I don't remember ever seeing say a gram
methamphetamine case adopted by the U.S
attorney's Office typically where we see
these cases adopted is a significant
amount of weight uh several kilos
several pounds of some type of illicit
narcotic great thank you thank you very
much
yes representative Lorenzo thank you Mr
chairman and
um forfeiture cases and my if my memory
stirs me correctly
um
the state
entities in a federal entities
have
um
they have like a fund
that fortune Pro funds are sunk into and
could you tell me what
typically
um
State
forfeiture money is how it's spent
thank you yeah absolutely thank you
ma'am for the question and uh yes I
alluded to it before but I can give you
some specifics so uh we do have both a
federal as well as a state forfeiture
account and those are kept separate
because there are separate guidelines uh
dictating what we can and cannot do with
those funds but what they are mandated
to be utilized for is law enforcement
purposes and what the state police uses
them for uh the vast majority of the
time is support of our narcotics unit
and that includes things that are
unexpected cost so we budget out for the
uh clearly the the budget is put forward
from the director that says hey we we
need five uh vehicles uh for this next
year however if uh on an icy road we
have a trooper who uh crashes that
vehicle and suddenly we need six
Vehicles we use that forfeiture fund to
account for un uh unanticipated cost for
the enforcement of Narcotics and the
same can be said for we have body wires
or cameras things that may reach end of
life at a time we didn't expect and we
will utilize that money to purchase a
new body wire or a new camera for the
purpose of narcotic enforcement
yes representative Lorenzo thank you
I'm going to rephrase that there's a
perception that forfeiture money goes to
the over militaryization of police
um
law enforcement would you speak to that
I mean we're talking about buying
Bearcats and all other kinds of
equipment almost you know War equipment
thank you sure yeah I I so uh
I can tell you that uh the the funding
that we use we spend on our narcotics
unit so in terms of what somebody May
deem as over military they say
militarization of law enforcement
um I think that's somewhat subjective
but I can tell you specifically things
that we purchase so Vehicles body wires
uh cameras surreptitious cameras that
are utilized in undercover cases that is
the type of uh that is what that funding
is used for I'm not aware of we have one
uh armored personnel carrier which is
the the State Police SWAT unit
um bear I'm not aware of what would you
what was utilized what funds were
utilized to purchase that although I
my understanding and again I I tell I
say this as my understanding of it and
not as fact is that that came through
grant money uh but in terms of uh
purchasing say rifles uh or uh something
along those lines that may lead more to
a military style uh level of enforcement
I'm not aware of any of these funds
being utilized for that but I'm happy to
if you have specific a specific question
about a specific item that you think may
have been purchased I'm more than happy
to research that present that to the
committee
rather yes representative Langley
is this fine now it is thank you I'm
sorry thank you for taking my question I
just want to be sure I'm clear
forfeiture cannot occur unless a person
has been convicted and has been found
guilty of something is that arrogant no
yes that's my understanding of what the
uh the previous iterations of house
legislation was but I to be quite honest
ma'am I didn't come prepared to speak on
that point
um but I but but again I'm happy to
provide a statement to the committee uh
that is definitive in nature okay
this the second part of this question
you may not be able to answer but if you
can research it I would appreciate it so
that would mean
that whatever was used in the commission
of the crime
that could be forfeited that's the only
that's the only
um
I'm just not being clear on this one
I'll just leave it at where I was thank
you understood thank you that's okay
other questions
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chairman
um I'd like to kind of get a a list from
you about what specifically
um the fund has been used for in the
past I think like kind of a detailed
list past couple years of what it's been
used for I think that'd be very valuable
at least to me and maybe other members
of the committee sure and representative
your last name I apologize Alexander
Alexander so uh
I will put that uh that request forward
to the uh to the director to the kernel
one thing I would ask you to consider
um
you're asking for purchases over the
last couple of years I I perceive that
there may be a concern over turning over
the purchases of the last couple of
years because of the covert nature of
the equipment that they were purchasing
if you're looking to see what is
purchased out of that account I think
purchases that were made perhaps three
or four years ago which are now no
longer being utilized in a covert nature
that is perhaps more easily elicit
obtained that I can provide right and
I'm not if it's covert like I'm not
asking for specifics but maybe some like
General line items would be great or
something like that and I mean we're not
talking about a lot of like money
necessarily I believe we're talking
about 170
000 over three years so it doesn't seem
like the list might be that long
understood the question I'm asking I
will absolutely uh get that to you would
you like that email to yourself or to
the chairman
I believe the the whole committee would
be great
thank you understood
okay are there any other questions
if not thank you Captain I thank you
very much for the opportunity to talk to
you this morning thank you thank you
there are some other people who signed
up I'm not sure that they are all here
but I see that our Committee Member
representative Sylvia is here would you
like to testify
thank you Mr chairman
representative Mike Sylvia
representing belknap6 down in Belmont
and and before you begin I want to
apologize because I know you let us know
that there would be difficulty with
regard to timing and I didn't expect the
prior hearing to go as long as it did so
oh no and in fact we kind of assumed
that Criminal Justice having a fairly
short schedule for their bills would be
running overtime but they're not they're
on time today so that's why there is a
train going back and forth with some of
the people that are testifying here I've
got two bills over there one of them's
15 minutes into it so hopefully they
haven't uh Gone looking for me yet I
think they have all the folks there
testifying in any case
um
I'd just like to address
um a concern in uh
uh you know we we have worked on civil
asset forfeiture over the years and the
gentleman from Westmoreland has been
very much involved in it is very very
much a bipartisan effort and we turned
our state law from civil asset
forfeiture into criminal asset
forfeiture
and
this is the the proper way to do
forfeiture I certainly should be a crime
and a conviction
and in most cases that will happen with
the state law that was passed in 2016 or
18.
um
so the state has
criminal asset forfeiture so
this is the reason why we are looking at
this Equitable sharing the adoption by
the federal court because those go into
a civil process where a conviction is
not required
and
this is something that's been
big throughout the country and the
institute for justice publishes a big
book of policing for profit
and this is something we want to avoid
we don't want the image that our law
enforcement are out you know building
their own budgets
uh budgeting is is a an affair for the
legislature or in the county the um the
delegation or in the town level the uh
the people vote on the budget and decide
how much that they want to fund to their
law enforcement
so this money that goes through
forfeiture uh goes back to law
enforcement and it is off budget it
it does not go through the normal
budgeting process it is money that they
have restrictions on but it is within
their own departments to decide how to
spend that in in the best way to do that
so
uh this bill that you've got this year
is slightly changed from last year we
passed out of committee 18-2
it went through the house on Voice vote
and ran into the folks on the other side
of the wall
um
and so one of the objections uh uh to
last year is Bill was a fairly arbitrary
uh limit of 100 000
to cut off the adoption process and keep
it in State uh the reality is that
the vast majority of forfeitures are
probably under ten thousand dollars
and
um
this is in a Range particularly if you
put this into a federal process where
you're not going to get very far in
legal fees before you chew up everything
that has been
um
taken and so a lot of that is just
forfeited it's just it's not even fought
for they just walk away from it it's a
default and you know and so that you
never get to the the point of finding
out whether or not there was actually a
crime involved so I think this is an
important bill I think we need to bring
it back to the other side of the wall
and uh and perhaps uh have them take
another look at it
questions for representative Sylvia
seeing none thank you thank you
we do have other people who signed up
Joshua Albert who indicated he opposes
the bill
I'm presuming that's the case there's uh
lee McGrath and Dennis Corrigan
I guess what I asked the committee is uh
do you want to recess the hearing or
close the hearing at this point in time
do you think we've heard sufficient
testimony
I think so I do
uh we'll close the hearing
on House Bill
and those people who perhaps didn't have
the opportunity to testify can submit
testimony if they wish to the committee
and we will be in recess for lunch and
reconvene at one o'clock
thank you everybody
that I lost and I was battling my way
through do one of those cards at all
those are the people who didn't testify
keep them fire we'll be part of the
permanent record
and there won't be anything in a minute
hi
okay
it's red like that see
thank you so thank you so much Mr chair
and thank you honorable members for
welcoming me to your committee
um for the record my name is Ellen Reed
I represent Newmarket newfields
Rockingham 17. and I have for you today
uh HB 1107
and I want to give you just a little bit
of history on this bill a couple years
ago I put in a bill that was not a study
committee version but an actual version
uh that would have basically the broad
point is to make it so that landlords
cannot arbitrarily uh deny uh people
renting who have pets there were a lot
of concessions to landlords in terms of
well what if an animal is disruptive or
what have you however the Committees
certainly felt that it was a very
complex issue and
um it did appear at that point that the
committee was going to adopt a study
committee amendment to that bill but
instead a non-germaine amendment was
adopted instead so I have this before
you now with the study committee in the
study committee version and so I'll just
go ahead and get into the meat of this
the first piece is I believe you've
received testimony in support of this
bill from several organizations a few of
them being the AKC an organization
called dogs hsus Humane Society of the
United States ASPCA best friends no kill
advocacy and I just want to point out
kind of the little small miracle in this
because and I don't know if these
organizations frequently testify in this
committee but there is virtually no
issue whatsoever where the AKC and dogs
agree with the SPCA and Humane Society
they are always always always at odds
and both of the directors of those
respective organizations were astonished
that they were on the same side on an
issue
so this particular issue I know that
members in our body are in general
sometimes reticent to pass a study
committee
but this is an issue and I understand
that because there's a lot of issues
that have been studied ad nauseam but
this is an issue that has never been
studied in this state
certainly there are states and other
locations that have kind of trailblazed
for us and have done some of the hard
work and studying done some of the hard
work in passing legislation different
forms of legislation on this issue but
we have not studied it in the
particulars of our state so I do feel is
very important to study
in terms of other locations California
and Illinois have both put a ban on no
pets Clauses when it comes to
state-funded housing any any kind of
housing that receives any kind of
subsidy Massachusetts has pushed forward
on a ban in regards to certain types of
dogs Oregon has a complete ban on no on
a no pets Clause Ontario has a complete
ban and that one's in particular is very
interesting because we have data that
shows before the ban
um there's pet surrenders to their
shelters 25 percent of them were due to
housing issues and after the ban that
dropped to six percent
Australia has a ban and in Australia I
kind of and I didn't find out about this
until after I put in the first bill so
just recently Australia's legislation or
their law now says that a tenant must
get the landlord approval but the
landlord cannot reasonably deny approval
and if the landlord wants to deny it the
landlord has to to show a reason why so
I kind of actually like it's a bit of an
elegant solution I think
but let me talk about the reasons why
this should be studied and why this is
an issue the idea of getting red rid of
the no pets clause in lease is first of
all and most Obviously good for pets
it's the number housing issues is the
number one reason pets are surrendered
to shelters which are a burden on on our
community at Large
and it's the number one reason that
people give that for not adopting
animals or taking in more animals so
it's a huge burden on shelters and this
has actually been going up the the
concern about housing when it relates to
pets has been something that's been
increasing
getting rid of no pet Clauses is
actually good for people as well not
Just Pets companion animals
um so as we probably have all heard but
many data's many Studies have shown that
companion animals substantially improve
cardiovascular and mental health and
especially in this time when many many
people are suffering from effects of
isolation
um also further more and more people are
choosing not to have children and more
and more people are living longer and
those are both factors that lead to more
isolated Lifestyles and in both of those
populations greatly benefit and intend
to actually embrace pet ownership
I would like to quote here there was a
in 1981 under the Reagan Administration
there was a national White House
conference on Aging
um and they address the problem of
elderly people having to choose between
housing that they could afford and their
companion animals and and this
conference actually in the report
um and again this was 1981 they framed
it as a civil rights issue the quote is
the forced separation of older persons
from their companion animals upon
entering housing projects for the
elderly inflicts immeasurable emotional
suffering and often leads to severe
psychological trauma and consequent
mental and physical deterioration
including the loss of the will to live
the comfort of a companion animal is a
civil right not to be denied to
responsible pet owners again that is
quote from the Reagan Administration
conference on Aging
but this is an issue that doesn't only
affect the Aged
and obviously we've already given many
uh considerations to people with
um therapy dogs or therapy animals for
certain disabilities but it affects
pretty much everyone who has animals
and so we already have a protected class
where animals have to be allowed in but
there are so many people that benefit
substantially physically and emotionally
from having animals
um so in further it's not only good for
the pet owner themselves but Studies
have shown and I will be sending you all
of my references so you can see those
studies and you're not just taking my
word there's studies but Studies have
shown that communities that allow more
pets report greater overall happiness
and social cohesion so it's actually
good for the whole community and when
surveyed most tenants regardless of
whether they personally wanted to have a
pet most tenants overwhelmingly support
allowing pets
further not only is it good for the
animals and good for people in general
but it's actually good for landlords now
hear me out first of all 47 of housing
um
allows for pets so it's less than half
but 47 percent is fairly substantial
it's enough to to draw data from and so
we know that with 47 of percent of
landlords allowing for housing for
people with pets that it is something
that continues to be lucrative it is
something that's doable it's not
something that's unfeasible
um on average and again I have the
studies that I'll send you pet owners do
not cause on average any more damage
than non-pet owning tenants
and uh so they're responsible and
irresponsible people
that have pets and don't have pets
that's it's spread uh across the board
and but not only that so most pets do
not cause damage of the damage that is
done by pets most of that damage is
within the normal security deposit again
I will send you those studies
um furthermore pets don't cause any more
damage than children so just anecdotally
and I I no longer have children that
live above me but I cannot tell you how
many times I've laid on the couch
reading a book with my cat curled up
quietly on my chest while I'm listening
to Children running back and forth
screaming and the mom yelling at them to
stop fighting and then there's toys
strewn about in our communal areas
so again children are protected but but
people with pets are not even though
that's become more and more of an option
for people instead of children
by the way children are protected
because of a federal
um
status called familial status but again
people choose not to have children and
choose to have pets instead of children
and that should be their right so in a
very serious way this means landlords
are unreasonably interfering with
private family decisions
again if the pet owner is responsible if
the pet owner is not causing any damage
is not causing any problems with other
tenants then why should the landlord
care whether or not they have a pet
also getting rid of no pets arbitrary no
pets Clauses is good for the housing
good for housing in general when we're
having a housing issue right now and the
housing market because it means that
everyone not only people who don't have
pets but everyone has access to the full
range of the housing market that's in
their budget which helps people secure
housing that is responsibly within their
means but also it helps competition in
the overall housing market
also it helps the economy in general
because pet ownership is a multi-billion
dollar industry that supports the
economy and when we say people are not
allowed to have pets or face eviction
then that means we're dampening that
industry
ah
so anyway people should not have to
choose between having a roof over their
heads and keeping a valued member of
their family especially one that brings
them comfort and companionship there are
multiple options like I glossed over
earlier but we have a lot of places that
are doing things and so these are the
types of things that we can study in a
study committee how other places are
doing it and also the stakeholders in
our state for example I did mention
Australia has this no unreasonable
denial clause which is a really kind of
elegant simple easy way to address the
situation
but I think we can also study a very
clear process that might involve things
like screening inspections monitoring of
complaints from other tenants and a
warning system to protect the landlord
and enable the landlord to quickly deal
with anything that might potentially
become a problem we can also look into
things like limiting it only to cats and
dogs possibly animals that are contained
to an closure requiring vaccinations
requiring spay and neuter requiring that
the animal is indoors all the time in
the case of dogs requiring insurance and
also the idea of just simply limiting
pet deposits and making them refundable
so after all this we know these things
for sure this is definitely an issue for
a huge number of people in this state
especially in our current housing crisis
and it further limits people's ability
to find housing we also know people are
happier and healthier with their
companion animals and we know that
animals are happier and healthier with
their people
we know that this is something that a
lot of places are already doing the
pioneering work for us and we know that
this is something that we have never
studied so for all those reasons I ask
that this committee support a study
committee and I'm happy to take
questions
thank you representative Reed are there
questions for the representative
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
presenting this bill to us
um so
um last term last year we had a bill
that would just um full-on prohibit
discrimination that you sponsored and
sent to us and that was passed out of
committee eventually tabled on the floor
of the house and from what my knowledge
or previous knowledge of this is that
there was some sort of compromise
Amendment between
landlords and you or some other group
that was that was
proposed and eventually passed but the
bill was tabled on the floor can you and
um
when it was tabled last year you voted
to table it I guess what I'm wondering
is what the process why you chose to do
that and then also
um what else are We additionally going
to learn from a study committee that we
didn't already discuss last year when
this bill came to us well actually it
was the landlord's Association that went
into great detail about how we hadn't
studied this issue and that there was
all this data that we needed to look
into about how landlords are impacted
the studies that I'm going to send you
tend to show that landlords in general
when they complain about pet damages
exaggerate when compared to actual costs
exaggerate the Damage Done but there
were stories from that term of pets
doing like a single dog doing like a
hundred thousand dollars damage right so
these are things that we definitely need
to look into and obviously the health
and well-being of people we didn't go
into those studies specifically for the
state and the housing issue but in terms
of what happened the amendment that I
was working on with my groups and the
Landlord Association we did try to work
on an amendment together and that was
the study committee that one was not
what was adopted and that was not what
was on the floor what ended up being on
the floor was a non-germaine amendment
that completely removed any mention of
pets whatsoever and simply raised with
no limit security deposits not pet
security deposits security deposits
something The Landlord Association has
been Desiring for a long time so it had
they used my bill as a vehicle for what
they wanted to do so that is why I posed
it on the floor and gave the unfortunate
speech of saying I'm asking for this
chamber to vote against my bill but uh
no that was it was the the bill on the
floor that I supported tabling was not
the amendment that I had worked with the
Landlord Association on that was the
study committee Amendment
are there other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you so much Mr chair
the next person who has filed a pink
card is Nick Norman
thank you very much committee for having
me speak today appreciate it very much I
have some written testimony here
I have 21 copies so there's way planning
I'll put it around to two sides
so I'm with the
I'm sure you're not unfamiliar with me
I'm with the apartment association of
New Hampshire and director for
legislative affairs for landlords across
the state involving landlord tenant
issues
every season
so we're in opposition to the bill
this was talked about a lot the last
time the original bill came through
and
pets
often cause a large amount of damage to
the property
so forcing a landlord
to accept a pet
would have you know extreme consequences
to
the housing
is often the case I would disagree with
the previous speaker about damages it's
often the case that a pet in an
apartment
causes some damage sometimes that is
covered by the security deposit
other times not at all
when a pet is urinating and
um
pooping in the apartment and you get
smell and
things leaking into the woodwork
sometimes you have to pull up and
replace flooring it would be very common
to have to replace carpeting sometimes
that gets into the wood
some of our members really have spent
thousands of dollars on one family that
have had a pet that was irresponsible
with their their ownership
there's also the case that
some percentage of people are allergic
to pets
they can't live in an apartment where
there has been an animal
no matter what you do for cleaning
some people are allergic enough that
they actually
could be risking death or extreme
physical medical consequences that might
be on the rare side but there's a very
large number of people that are allergic
to dander and and pets and they don't
want to have to live in a building where
there is a pet or in an apartment where
there was a pet
the recovery of damages from a tenant in
our court system is practically
impossible
when a tenant leaves and they've created
damage
you try to do small claims it's almost
impossible to collect on that
damage and there's certainly not enough
security deposit to cover the damage
that often is caused by a pet
sometimes it is
what about emergencies and you have a
defensive dog in the apartment the
landlord is trying to handle an
emergency but you can't get in because
there is a defensive dog there
and what about all the other tenants in
the property that are complaining
because there's a dog barking or the the
owner doesn't pick up after their dog on
the property and you've given many many
warnings but you can't remedy the
behavior and then it's a two-month
eviction period after all of those
warnings and then all the other tenants
have to put up with that
forcing a landlord to accept pets or
Bridges the owner's rights to screen
tenants and to create a quiet enjoyment
for the other tenants in the property
if the bill if it turns out that the
legislature comes up with a plan that
forces landlords to accept pets
it's going to increase the cost
of managing the property taking care of
the property all those costs are going
to be turned back into higher rents it's
going to exacerbate the affordable
housing issue that we have
Insurance costs will rise because of the
number of feds
we need to be putting our effort into
creating more affordable housing
not worsening the housing
affordability that we already have
we think that the original bill was a
very bad idea we think that there's no
good that can come from a study
committee because the idea of forcing
owners to accept pets is just a bad idea
is going to create
liabilities expenses
increased insurance
less enjoyment for the other tenants in
the property and
I I don't see any good that could come
from even studying it I would be very
happy to take questions
are there any questions for Mr Norman
yes representative page
thank you Mr Norman for taking my
question thank you um
representative Reed
had mentioned that she had studies I
believe that sort of supported some of
her statements and she was going to send
those to this committee
I'm wondering to what extent you have
similar studies that might support some
of the statements that you have here I
have testimony from landlords and my own
experience
but I don't have studies
actually it's not an issue that I've
studied and researched in that kind of a
way
but I have plenty of experience in the
industry so it's it's largely your
anecdotes right
from my constituent landlords and I talk
with the landlords thousands of
landlords across the state okay and plus
I have my own 48 units
thank you thanks for taking my question
I would be very interested to have the
studies
if
yeah that'd be awesome yeah just focus
on the committee if you would thanks
thank you and
other yes representative Nutter thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking the
question thank you isn't it true that
there's also uh rental properties
um apartments and whatever that that do
not allow human children
do not allow human children I am totally
unaware of that except
for like senior housing there's a grade
of
housing for people that are 55 or older
or 62 or older I'm not sure of the
number but there is authorized elderly
housing that can only have people above
a certain age
follow-up yes
I'm confused because I have a friend who
lives in Merrimack she used to live in
apartments they turned condo and they
had to move because they had a child
so maybe that maybe it became a senior
student
senior housing it could be that it's a
senior housing it had been transformed
into a senior housing is totally illegal
to
not allow children based on
discrimination of familial status
it's very clear
other questions
the only question I had Mr Norman is do
you think that we could reform the small
claims process to make it easier to
collect I would love to be on that
committee if we
may take 30 seconds if you want to
address affordable housing
a huge step
in that direction would be to make small
claims productive
and a simple idea
is to offer to Property Owners seeking
damages from tenants the same
process as someone seeking child support
for instance we're pretty good
at forcing child support
as a society but we're absolutely
terrible at having tenants cause damage
that is never collected and then it goes
passed on to other tenants
thank you I'm off the soapbox yeah I
should never have asked the question
thanks but I'll gladly step on
is there any other questions for Mr
Norman thank you for your testimony
today thank you so much
uh and Kurt Ehrenberg
uh
I think I'll take off my mask uh
my name is Kurt Ehrenberg I'm the state
director for the Humane Society of the
United States
happy to be here today and support
of this study committee
um
and I do have written testimony I didn't
make enough copies
but I have one to furnish to the
committee hopefully
we'll get one to everyone I can email
them I won't read the whole thing just a
few paragraphs
and I'll just say uh although pet
friendly housing has become more common
the industry standard for pet friendly
still contains limitations and
restrictions on types ages and sizes of
pets that severely restrict the rental
housing market
these policies are based on
misinformation and myth rather than data
and property managers who established
such arbitrary restrictions are missing
out on large segments of the pet owning
population
nearly 85 million U.S households in an
estimated 72 percent of renters have a
pet
now we believe housing issues should
never cost pets their homes which is a
significant concern for many families
each year millions of pets enter animal
shelters
and one of the most frequently cited
reasons for relinquishment
is a housing moving or landlord issue
breed size or weight restrictions and
the limited amount of rental housing
that will allow animals
creates many obstacles for renters with
pets that lack of accessible housing can
have disastrous consequences some
families are forced to relinquish their
pets to shelters ripping those families
apart often with detrimental impacts on
their physical and emotional well-being
others may choose to hide their pet
despite the risk of jeopardizing their
housing rather than give up a beloved
companion
and I'll just say there are many
benefits for housing providers with
policies that welcome pets such as an
increase in their pool of potential
renters and a decrease in their turnover
costs because they gain longer term more
stable residents on average pet owners
stay in a rental property twice as long
as those without pets while only 10
percent of pet owners have ever lost a
security deposit
10 percent of pet owners have ever lost
a security deposit and pet owners are
not statistically more likely to damage
rental units and these are all backed up
and I'll give you the citations Property
Owners can also take additional
precautionary measures when leasing to a
pet owning tenant such as requiring a
reasonable pet deposit for potential
damages and proof of vaccinations for
the pet
not the human both measures are
accounted for in this bill so again this
is a study
bill it has notwithstanding the previous
bill that as a representative Reed
alluded to was poison pilled
in the last
time around so this is a study committee
so to have the tenant uh the The
Landlord Association say that no good no
good can come
out of a study committee that affects
72 percent of the people that rent
housing in this state
um
it just doesn't make sense to me I
appreciate your time and I'm happy to
take questions
questions for Mr Ehrenberg
yes representative Langley
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Ehrenberg can
you tell me do you know in terms of
public housing are pets allowed in those
facilities or those rental units
the Federal
uh
Federal housing pets are allowed
basically is the answer to that yes
thank you follow up Mr Speaker yes do
you do you have any understanding as to
why it's more manageable in public
housing as opposed to what one of the
previous speakers alluded to in terms of
private housing
I do I do not thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 1107.
seeing no one we will close the hearing
and that brings us to our next hearing
which is on House Bill 11 33.
prohibiting the termination of Elise
during the sale of property
I do have some
cards here
I was looking for the uh oh
representative adjutant do you have a
card to submit
representative adjutant you're the prime
sponsor of the bill would you like to
introduce it
all right thank you Mr chairman and
members of the House Judiciary Committee
thank you for having me today
here to introduce HB 1133 a bill aimed
at stopping evictions where the single
case for eviction is the property
changes hands
this bill would require the new landlord
who purchases a building with tenants in
it honor the leases for the remainder of
their original agreement
it does not mean the landlord is
required to renew it does not mean the
renter you know if the renter just stops
paying rent that the landlord has to
continue to honor the lease it's
specifically and only creates a
protection where the sale of the
building is the only reason a person
would otherwise be evicted as you'll
hear today this does happen in the state
of New Hampshire I was inspired to
submit the bill after a pretty severe
acquisition of a building in Concord
where unfortunately a bunch of poor and
disabled folks found themselves with
30-day notices to get out when they
thought they had longer and were current
on their bills with no other issues and
I didn't think that was right and so
here's the bill
why this is necessary especially now in
my opinion is because the temperature of
the housing market in the state of New
Hampshire buildings can have dozens of
cash offers the day that they're put on
the market they can be sold in days and
all of a sudden a tenant is who is under
the impression that they have seven
months in a lease can find out they have
30 days to find a new place to live near
work near their kids school which
wouldn't be as big a deal if we didn't
have such an insanely low vacancy rate
to boot I really fear that folks put in
that situation through no fault of their
own again who are current on all of
their bills and have no other issues may
end up with housing or may end up
without housing
there there's an argument that I've
heard floated around that
in most cases uh a court will side on
the on behalf of the tenant
unfortunately the word most is doing a
lot of heavy lifting in that sentence
and I just think having something firm
in the RSA would be better
there is one thing that I would ask the
committee to consider and it is an
amendment that I've already discussed
with a Committee Member to change the
word non-restricted to restricted just
so it broadens the scope
unfortunately I'm not as familiar with
landlord and tenant law as I would like
to be so in trying to craft that bill
the distinction between non-restricted
and restricted slipped by me but
changing that to restricted would
broaden the scope I spoke to Mr Elliott
Berry and he had wisely made that
suggestion
um but that's all I have so I would once
again further clarify so that it doesn't
accidentally Get Lost in Translation
that the sole purpose of this bill is to
just say that if your building changes
hands and you have seven months left on
that lease as long as you're current on
everything as long as there's no other
reason as long as you don't burn the
building down as long as you don't stop
paying rent you stay there for the
remainder of the lease I think it will
help keep a couple more people's lives
whole and that's what we're looking for
so I can take any questions
questions
representative Lorenzo
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative adjutant um so
I thought that
it's already illegal to terminate a
lease upon the sale of a property type
of property
uh that was not my understanding
um I I can't answer that 100
um I in in the research that I did
um there's still an opportunity uh for
that lease to be terminated uh after it
changes hands I'm not sure that
protection exists in New Hampshire I'm
open to being wrong
um but I I think that having this line
in the RSA would be helpful
about what
um representative you mentioned
evictions in conquered what a particular
property was sold and you had said that
all the tenants received an eviction
notice
and my understanding from the newspaper
articles that I read was that the
tenants
rent went to Market rent and they were
served rent increased notices
and then the victims followed after that
when the tenants you know could not pay
or couldn't afford to pay the market
rent is that correct
um
that might be
um I would
it might be my understanding when I read
that
um was that
um there were folks that were serving
those eviction notices
um and
um even if that specific example
um isn't practical uh in this
application for every tenant there are
still situations in the state of New
Hampshire where buy a property Changing
Hands
um those individuals are eligible for an
eviction there's actually another bill
that will deal with something similar
although I don't feel like it goes far
enough so we have this
but I just think having this protection
the rsas would be beneficial
representative Alexander um thank you Mr
chair thank you representative I believe
so representative Lynn had a bill last
year that would allow for determination
of a lease upon the sale of property so
I guess I'm confused on what the RSA
says because I thought we were we voted
that out of the committee last year
enabling
eviction Upon A termination of lease and
now there's another bill coming to us
about termination of lease like
prohibiting it so I guess I'm wondering
where the RSA stands I think
representative Delorenzo is also kind of
bringing that up because
um we were under the impression that
it's
that
that is not allowed to happen
uh are you aware as to whether or not
that uh Bill became law last year
okay
um it was killed in the Senate okay
um yeah I I understand
um that there may be some confliction on
that uh I'm happy to double check there
when I read the statute that I was
looking to amend uh it didn't it just it
basically said like an eviction can
happen and then what I was trying to do
was put a comma at the end of that
sentence and say provided that the
exchange of ownership of a property is
not the reason for eviction
um so it adds that line in there
um as a specific uh you can evict except
for this
are there any other questions
I guess uh the question I'd have
representative adjudon is I'm not aware
of any circumstances
uh
except where Justice might require
in the superior court and these matters
are all done in the Circuit Court
Circuit Court doesn't have Equity power
to invalidate a contract
I'm not aware of any circumstances where
the court has authority to invalidate a
legal contract between two private
parties
and I guess I'm very curious to know if
and I'm not aware of any circumstance
where
just based upon the fact that there was
a change in the ownership of a property
that somebody was evicted
are you other than the example you gave
a Congress are you aware of any
circumstance where that happened I I had
a couple people lined up to speak to
that today I without looking behind me
don't know if they're here or not
um but uh you know my my like I said my
reading of that RSA was this is allowed
to happen trying to put the comma in
there and put the last line of uh except
for this so that's just what I'm looking
to do
foreign
any other questions
thank you representative thank you
and I'll call upon Nick Norman
thank you much again
Mr chairman again I have written
testimony
I I just comment that we do have a
number of people who want to speak so if
you can make your testimonies quite
brief
ly so I won't bother with the
introduction because we talked about
that before and you know me well
I've been in real estate since 1987.
and I can unequivocally tell you that a
lease is a contract
you are correct
and that a sale of a property does not
void the contract of a lease if it's
during the term of the lease
this common knowledge in real estate is
taught in real estate schools
on my core team of people that analyze
bills for me there's attorneys and I
reviewed this with two of the attorneys
on the team
um
a lease
supersedes the sale
unquestionably
you're correct Delorenzo I think your
mic might be off when you speak
um
so I mean that that's it bill is
unnecessary we already have this
protection in the law adding a clause to
the law about this just creates
confusion in the law because there's
other parts of the law that talked about
good cause and evictions and so forth
so we're we're against the bill because
it's unnecessary that is already the law
you cannot sell you cannot terminate a
lease because of the sale of a property
if it's during the term of the lease and
the lease hasn't expired
there is the possibility that both
parties could agree
a landlord and a tenant could agree that
they have a clause in their lease that
allows for the lease to be
terminated if the property is sold but
that is an agreement between the
landlord and the Tenant and that's
extremely unusual I've never seen it but
I've heard that it sometimes happens
I'm ready for any questions
for Mr Norman
yes representative Chase
I'm sorry I have one question thank you
so much what about
um when you're doing a month-to-month
lease
so on a month-to-month lease there's no
term
so you can that comes under good cause
eviction and this allowed under the RSA
to sell the property
to terminate the lease for the sale of
the property in that situation
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and representative Reed
to testify
thank you Mr chair and honorable members
I have to full disclosure I had no idea
this bill existed I was in here anyway I
saw it I read it and I I have my own
story to tell on this because there
seemed to be questions about whether or
not this happens now I cannot speak to
New Hampshire but just so you know my
background I grew up in South Memphis a
very impoverished urban area
and my family rented a house it was the
best place we ever lived and we were
quite happy there the elderly owner of
that property died and it went to his
son his son sold the property and didn't
that obviously the the new owners did
not own uh honor the lease and my family
was out on their ear the only place they
could find on such short notice was
honestly it was I don't believe it was
actually legally allowed to be rented it
was a a trailer that didn't have proper
heat or running water so
um that is the kind of impact that that
can have for a family to not be able to
plan ahead now again I just wanted to
share that background
um but I cannot speak to specifics and I
didn't know this bill was up I don't
know what the case is in New Hampshire
but if it is something that landlords
can do
um then I would suggest that you pass
this Bill thank you
are there any questions for
representative Reed
sign thank you for your testimony
Stephen Tower
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm going to try to speak
up it's my first time testifying in this
new pandemic World
um I'm here representing New Hampshire
legal assistance I'm here in place of my
colleague Elliot Berry who has not been
able to make it today
um we at nhla are a non-profit Law Firm
we provide free legal services for
low-income families and seniors and
among the work that we do is eviction
defense for attendance so we are sort of
familiar with this area of law
as the law currently stands there is not
anything in the rsas or any Supreme
Court case law that states that a a a
lease can be terminated because of the
sale of the property or that it cannot
be it's it's just not written into our
law as it is I believe it's a common law
principle that the lease runs with the
land uh currently it is our experience
at nhla over several decades of work
that
um in any case where we have received an
eviction notice that our clients have
received that they are being evicted
because of the sale of the property we
have been able to get those cases
dismissed because the lease currently
runs with the land
um as representative adjutant noted
though there are definitely instances
where someone will receive an eviction
notice
for termination of the lease upon sale
of the land and
um if it's not in the RSA neither the
the landlord nor the tenant know that
this is currently a legal Principle as
it exists in New Hampshire although the
judges will if it is raised as a defense
um so I imagine most of those tenants
that representative Edgington described
would not know that they could file a
motion to dismiss the eviction case
based on the principle that the lease
continues to run with the land after the
sale
um and so for that reason I think there
is a benefit to including that in the
text of our rsas
it also May potentially save some
landlords a the cost of a filing and
service fee in an eviction case where us
uh Troublesome legal aid attorneys come
in and end up getting the case dismissed
and then they've lost a couple hundred
bucks on the filing fees
um
now we we did have a concern about the
the bill as written because as it is
written it it refers to the transfer of
title to a non-restricted property shall
not be caused to terminating the
tendency for the duration of the current
lease term and we are a little concerned
that as written that would have sort of
a negative implication that in a
restricted property
uh the transfer of title can be cause
for a termination of the tendency
um and uh that would be concerning to us
as the majority of rental units in New
Hampshire are restricted property
um for to be clear a non-restricted
property is generally an owner-occupied
apartment building with four more units
um a single-family home where the owner
of the single family homes owes three or
more single-family homes or a property
that has been received as a result of a
foreclosure or tax deeding anything else
which is the majority of rental units is
considered a restricted property so that
potential negative inference of only
this this cause only being covered by
non-restricted property is a concern to
us uh I I circulated a proposal to amend
this that um attorney Elliott Berry
drafted up earlier today
which would instead add a clause to RSA
540 colon 2
that states that the
that in general the termination of a
tendency is not I'm sorry that a
transfer of title is not grounds for
termination of a tendency and we include
it in their uh some language that there
is an exception for foreclosure and tax
deeding and the reason that that is in
there is in a situation of a foreclosure
or a tax deeding it is actually the the
person receiving the property transfer
the in the uh the mortgagee the mortgage
or mortgage or uh actually has a
superior Grant of of title to the to the
property and the their interest in the
property actually supersedes the lease
and so in that case uh in the transfer
where it is a foreclosure or tax deeding
in those instances the the the lease
can be terminated by the what is
essentially the superior right holder
the the mortgager or the the tax Keating
and we wanted to include that in there
in case this amendment is adopted uh
because we thought the our colleagues in
the banking industry would be concerned
if that was not in there because it
would negatively impact their existing
rights
are there any questions Mr Tower
seeing none thank you very much
testimony today
is there anyone else who would like to
testify on House Bill 1133 yes sir
do you have a pink card oh yes I do okay
you could just turn it in after you
testify it would be fine thank you
hi my name is uh Brandon Lemay uh for
the record I am from Manchester New
Hampshire uh I am the housing Justice
organizer for rights and democracy
Mr Lemay yes for the record could you do
that do that tomorrow so I could
actually record it yeah sorry about that
uh I think I drank a little too much
coffee before this
uh yeah so my name is Brandon Lemay I'm
the housing Justice organizer for rights
and democracy uh where Grassroots
organization working to strength
Democratic participation and bring the
concerns of underserved Granite Staters
to the State House
I'm also speaking in favor of this bill
on behalf of the Manchester housing
Alliance and we are just a coalition of
Manchester residents who want to secure
our safe affordable housing for all of
our residents in the city
uh so I am test uh testifying on behalf
of our members again in support of hb133
uh we are calling this the limiting
evictions and stop escalating
homelessness act or lease act for short
uh over the past year I have joined
rights and democracy members in knocking
doors in the middle and low-income
neighborhoods particularly around
Manchester
we frequently hear stories about tenants
who after living in their apartment for
years or decades find that their
landlord has sold the property to a new
owner often out of state
it's standard to evict current tenants
to renovate the units and rent them out
at a higher rate pricing our most
vulnerable residents out of their
neighborhood we tend to call this
renovation
there's a high demand and low housing
stock so an eviction notice is at best
stressful
one eviction or bad credit score could
put a tenant at risk for homelessness
burdening or already full shelters here
in the city of Manchester
hb133 would simply let tenants finish
out leases they signed with their
landlords and enable them to plan
accordingly without undue stress and
inadequate time to transition
staying the remainder of Elise could be
the difference between a kid finishing
grade school with their friends and
potentially having to move out of state
it means that people can take more
control over their lives by reducing the
stress of having to suddenly find an
apartment in a tight market and this is
why I recommend that this committee
votes yes on this bill so thank you very
much
you have the questions for Mr Lemay
I guess the basic question Mr Lemay is
are you aware of circumstances where
people who are
in in a lease Arrangement have been
evicted by the courts yeah unfortunately
I wanted to bring one of those people
here today but they couldn't get out of
their shift
um yeah so like I said we call it
renovation
and it's pretty common especially
because we have such a hot housing
market here so a lot of people are
buying up properties and then hoping to
rent them out at a more expensive rent
every month
did I answer your question or
yes you did okay thank you
find it contrary to law but I do yeah I
just think this would make things a lot
more clear and it would it would just
make things a lot easier and less
stressful for renters
representative Langley
thank you Mr chair
could I ask you a question in terms of a
follow-up to the chairs question
do the notices that the tenants receive
actually say they're being evicted
because the property has changed hands
or does it happen more subtly and people
receive perhaps an increase in their
rent and aren't able to make that and as
a result feel they're being evicted
under those circumstances
I would say the most common type is a
constructural eviction
so basically
um they wouldn't usually buy the
property they want to renovate it so
then that's how they usually end up
doing it it's always usually followed up
by a rent increase too
okay so that's usually in tandem thank
you
[Music]
are there other questions
seeing none thank you Mr May thank you
for hearing me
again is there anyone else who would
like to testify on House Bill 1133
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on House Bill 1133
and we will briefly recess until two
o'clock and we will then begin our
hearing on our next bill
foreign
thank you
please
no I'll send this electron
ICS
Community right
okay
that's why
you know
oh Lord
there's so much
thank you sir
sir your um your mic isn't on
thank you so much
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to provide some information
on the amendment I'm proposing
as we all know the housing appeals board
has been a has been a hot potato debate
for a while and one of my goals with it
with this was to bridge the gap one of
the main goals is to bridge the gap on
maybe some of the the critiques that I
hear about the potential makeup of the
housing appeals board and some of the
potential conflict of interest to build
that in so we can
bring both sides maybe closer together
on the the benefits or the the pluses of
what the housing appeals board could do
I propose has changed because although
RSA 679 addresses have processes
thoroughly
I think that their continued room for
some additional conflict of interest
language and protections and also
clarifying some of the procedures during
temporary board vacancies
I did propose an amendment when I had
originally submitted this LSR in October
I had some original language in there
and then after some long discussions I
spent quite a bit of time speaking to
Representative Bob Lin
former Supreme Court Justice and he and
I talked about this at length and I
decided to tweak that language a little
bit so that's what that amendment is
about I gave you all a copy and I'll
obviously send it to you electronically
as well one of the things that I also
handed out to you is uh the sheet it
says explanation for HP 1254 and
proposed amendment I like visual aids
they help me so I just thought maybe
you'd be easy for us to follow along
together that way
so in that you can see the bolded
language is the places where I'm
tweaking the language or the bolded
text is the places where I'm tweaking
the language to 679. there's two
sections where I'm tweaking this
language 679 one
and 679 colon 8.
in the first section the reasons for the
changes the first reason for the change
in 679 colon 1 is to increase the
ability of the hab
to have a board member with Municipal
planning expertise versus just citing
that they have Housing Development
expertise
codifying this diverse language and the
diverse capability to the have makeup
will increase the balance decision
making
and it also actually address some of the
criticism I've heard is that
that there isn't maybe some
representation for the municipals on
that on that board although this won't
allow for a municipal to be on that
board per se perhaps somebody with some
Municipal planning expertise also could
be add in as well at the discretion of
the Supreme Court
one of the things that's on there as
well again a slight tweak to the
language of a professional land surveyor
license in the state of New Hampshire
the reason for that obviously is to
acknowledge and codify the professional
requirements of land surveyors the board
of land surveyors exist just for this
reason to regulate in licensing land
surveyors so I thought it would be
appropriate since we stated in there
that a lawyer
licensed practice in New Hampshire and
we also codify that for land surveyors
as well
the last part that you'll see in there
is the conflict of interest language at
the bottom and that was built in
to just to provide some additional
protections for people if they feel like
what if the what if the board has a
conflict of interest what if what if
they're making decisions that are
they're going to benefit them personally
that I know that that's actually been
quite of a concern that I've heard that
people are concerned that some of the
decisions are going to be made Might
financially benefit somebody who might
be on that board
so this adds it in this actually came
right from RSA 21g colon 22 which
actually deals with a code of ethics
with regard to the executive branch but
it's it's useful language here as well
as far as section 679 colon 8 goes when
you get to Temporary board members
the one thing that I have on here is
that I have that the Supreme Court
not the board will be in charge of
appointing temporary members
I felt that this was important and this
was something I actually discussed with
with boblin as well representative Lynn
and he he thought that that was a that
that was an appropriate change as well
again I'm trying to bridge the gap
between some of the criticism I hear
about the hab that maybe a decision
could be made somebody could be brought
in at the last minute on a temporary
basis that would make a decision that
was more favorable to one project or
another but by having the Supreme Court
actually be involved in that process
directly and not the board members that
that nullifies that that debate
and then the last change that I have on
there as well is that in the infant of a
vacancy on the board before in the
language it says if the appellant agrees
that they could proceed with the case
but the reason I built this language in
because the appellant shouldn't be the
only person there's other two parties in
that case maybe multiple maybe three but
the appellant shouldn't be the only
person who gets to decide if a case gets
to proceed during a temporary board
situation a temporary board member or
vacancy on the board so all this does is
this builds in language that says if
there's a vacancy on the board everybody
gets to to have a say in that
so those are the
the gist of the changes I have I'm happy
to take any questions
questions for representative hamola
I have a basic question we have sort of
three related bills
yes uh there's this bill which would
make changes to the board as it exists
there's a bill submitted by
representative Boyd I think just to
repeal the board and then there is a
third bill from representative Lynn who
which would create a separate Docket in
the Superior Court which if in fact we
adopted that there would be some
question as to whether or not the
housing board would be needed so do
do you believe that this approach is the
preferential approach or do you support
one of the other approaches
well with regard to representative Lin's
Bill uh I don't really fully know the
details on how that would play out I
would like to see that a little bit more
I would support either or whether we
move towards representative Lynn's
approach or whether we have the hab and
we try to create some of the language in
there that
that nullifies the concerns that people
have and make them feel more comfortable
that the hab is going to be fair
so whichever way that goes all I want is
for it to be fair and for people to have
confidence in that and for the have if
we're going to have the have then we're
going to
you know make sure that it doesn't have
um
I don't know how exactly to put this but
it doesn't have a false impression of
being a boogeyman
it just is what it is and it's allowed
to function well without undue criticism
if it doesn't um
it's just allowed to function I mean I I
guess what I'm saying is that one of the
things one of the things I thought was
really
um just in all disclosure I actually had
this bill was a lot bigger it was a lot
deeper there was a lot of cuts I just
went for it and then I actually did a
lot of homework on it and I talked to a
lot of people and in that process I
realized why it was written the way it
was why the language was what it was why
the fact that the appointment of board
members is different than 99 percent of
other board members I I found all those
answers out and at the end of the day I
couldn't see that making deeper cuts to
that was something that I was
comfortable with because it was already
crafted in a way that had a lot of
thought to it but it still did have room
to increase some conflict of language
interest to give people some more
reassurances that this will be a fair
body
thank you representative Alexander
um thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you representative
um
so the housing appeals board was passed
recently signed into law through the
state budget last year and since then
there's been like less than 15 decisions
rendered from the board do you feel like
this bill to try to fix something that
is really in the infant stages is even
needed because we we have we don't
really have a holistic idea of what the
board has done yet do you think we
should wait and kind of see maybe a lot
of the concerns around the board could
be alleviated with time that's a good
question thank you and and I will say
when my originally when I was originally
taking taking this RSA and
writing all over it that would have been
a that would have been a legitimate
legitimate concern that maybe hey wait
and see how it happens but regardless of
whether they've had those 15 cases or 50
more the language that's put in there
actually I believe makes sense because
of the fact that it's not it's not
changing anything they do
it's not changing their decisions it's
merely just putting in a little bit of
protection for conflict of interest in a
little bit of assurance for people that
during situations of temporary board
members or vacancies that it will remain
consistently Fair during that process
and I don't think that that's anything
whether it's 15 or going into the future
that doesn't change I don't see this as
a germane issue to what they do
any other questions yes representative
Simpson
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um you have mentioned something about
how the board is not functioning well or
something like that or how do we let it
function I just wondered I'm not as
familiar about about how um what how
people perceive it's functioning and I
wondered if you could talk a little more
about that sure I wasn't referring that
the board wasn't functioning well oh
okay what I was saying is that of the
camp of we want the hab to the camp of
we don't want the hab
some of the things that I hear are and
some of the things that people bring to
me in my in my town as well and then
also in the legislature the some of the
state reps
there is a concern that the hab quite
frankly could go in and just overturn
all these Municipal decisions there's
concerns that it it could be uh
the boogeyman that it in in some Theory
because it's just going to go over and
and take out local control and I I
understand those concerns and we've only
had 15 cases so I'm not addressing what
they do but I am what I am trying to do
is build in some reassurance to people
that are over in the camp here of having
those concerns of what if could happen
What could happen if this happens what
if they have a temporary board member
and somebody uh brings somebody on that
they know they'll vote a certain way I'm
trying to actually just make that fair
so that that actually doesn't happen in
some ways these are protections for the
hab so that they can function without
unneeded criticism that's how I see this
does that make sense does that answer
your question
yes that does thank you very much
representative Alexander thank you just
one more follow-up it seems like this
bill and amendment is trying to kind of
address concerns about
qualifications for board members on the
hab but I guess what I'm wondering is if
we're going to do this on the level of
the hab should we then
um propose to you know require mandatory
training on zoning and planning board
procedures for our local boards you know
what's the difference why are we
requiring it here and not somewhere else
so the only thing that I changed
as far as qualifications on the board
there was no changes other than adding
in Municipal planning saying that
somebody could have
experience in Housing Development and
Municipal planning that's the only thing
so I really don't know I'm not really
understanding your question I'm so sorry
I guess the question is is that
um there were
um things proposed about more
requirements for becoming a local
planning or Zoning Board member or maybe
more educational opportunities and you
know this amendment is addressing
educational opportunities or
requirements for members on the housing
appeals board I was wondering if you
think that you know local Planning and
Zoning Board officials should have
access or have certain you know
requirements or
qualifications needed to serve on their
board that might be a potential
conversation at another time but for
this regard all I'm speaking on today is
is really this amendment to RSA 679
thank you though
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
I note that we do have several people to
testify and we have a relatively
short window to do that but so if you
could be succinct that would be that
would be great I will call next upon
representative Chase who I understand is
speaking on behalf of Senator quoka
thank you very much Mr chair and yes I
am speaking on behalf of the senator who
was unable to be here due to a conflict
in scheduling
uh that what she would like to say is
that she is in support of these bills in
the housing appeal board is an
alternative for reviewing of housing
related cases the board is specifically
designed to provide administrative
efficiencies subject matter expertise
and adjective
education so are you saying that wrong
after a local reviews are exhausted this
is similar to a board of tax and land
Appeals
the house appeal board is designed to
make sure that all of our systems are
working efficiently as possible is New
Hampshire towns and cities try to
respond to Market demands for more
housing a court review
process can be time consuming and
expensive and it can even result in
projects not being built after it's
completed with the local zoning process
we want to ensure that affordable
housing developers do not and in the
case of certain developers we know they
cannot pass the cost of the litigation
on to the consumers there is a need for
subject matter expertise in the review
process for housing related appeals
which the housing appeal board provides
there are many myths about the housing
appeal boards that I feel should be
corrected the housing appeal board
cannot rewrite local Municipal zoning
ordinance modify local Municipal
subdivision regulations
reverse its site plan regulations change
local municipal or Master plans or
change rules and regulations from
Conservation Commission or historic
district commissions the housing appeal
board uses the same standards for care
for case I'm sorry case review as the
Superior Court
board seats are not politically
appointed housing appeal board members
are appointed by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court the housing appeal board
is a tool in the toolbox arming us with
high quality technical expertise in lieu
of litigation process I support the
housing appeal board and as such opposed
I'm so sorry I said support in the
beginning I'm so sorry that she opposes
both the HB
15 1254 and HB 12 16. please feel free
to reach out if I can be of any further
assistance thank you very much Senator
Rebecca Perkins
Cola Senate District 21. thank you and I
will take no questions
representative Chase
yes
let's turn into the whole Judiciary
Community just to you
it was
I think it it says that it went to the
chair but I will make sure that it does
I think I remember getting one from her
but then she's my Senator so maybe she
sent one special to me
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Bob Guida
Senate District Two
and Prime sponsor of the bill that was
the origin of the housing appeals board
I want to step back and provide a little
bit of background on why this came to be
um we have a a critical housing shortage
in our state
and when I stopped back and look at what
was happening it became apparent
that frankly local planning boards
were effectuating policy of their own
that was not consistent with State
Workforce housing laws okay
and so I it took us a couple of years to
get this bill through and to establish
the board
speaking to this particular bill of
Representative formula I'm concerned I
support the bill I didn't have a copy of
the latest iteration
uh I'm concerned with the municipal
planning piece
understanding that the municipal
planners already had
the entire process up to and through the
exhaustion of every Appeals mechanism at
the local level in which to make their
case
and that to appeal to a municipal
planner or okay potentially on the board
would be potentially
prejudicing that board in its
decision-making process okay
so that part of the bill I would I would
ask you to carefully consider the rest
of it I don't have a problem with I
think if we can establish you know
cleaner guidelines that's fine
um
conflict of interest that's fine
um but that one concerning piece there's
also
um
on line 12 of amendment
0067 which I believe is representative
homologous condensation of the first
part of the of her original bill
uh
I'm not sure
indirect what indirectly effect means
all right so that might require us a
little bit more definition definition
I mean I'm indirectly affected by
something Joe Biden does
sometimes I'm directly into and so that
to me is concerning yes we want clean
but we don't want it so clean that
anything that's possible to happen would
result in a possible disqualification of
members so that might require some cons
some
some some look again I I asked the
committee to look at that and with that
I'll conclude my testimony on uh
Amendment zero zero six seven to twelve
fifty four
questions for Senator Guida
thank you for your testimony today thank
you Mr chair
Ben Frost
has asked for three minutes
and Mr chairman I will endeavor to stick
to that
thank you very much I'll Endeavor to
hold you to it good afternoon I'm Ben
Frost from New Hampshire housing I have
a letter that I'll distribute but
recognizing that there is an amendment
that you have and that I've not seen
that uh that there are portions of the
letter that are no longer germane but
I'll stick to what um what has been
spoken to earlier with regard to the
amendment I'll try to anyway
um our position is of opposition to the
bill is introduced and I recognize what
Senator Guida said and what the
representative homeless has said about
the proposed amendment
um I think there are a couple issues
that remain El Echo Senator guide us
concerns about Municipal planning but I
have not seen the language yet so I
can't really comment on the specifics of
it
um
I believe that the conflict of interest
issue is already addressed in RSA
chapter 679 and if you look at
lines seven through nine of the the bill
is introduced you see the existing
language that deals with conflicts and
this was carefully drawn recognizing
that no member should be serving on the
housing appeals board on a case on the
housing appeals board where they have a
conflict of interest it's the sort of
conflicts that we deal with
at the municipal level with board
members and that judges deal with in any
case they have before them no no board
members should be hearing a case in
which they have a conflict I think
that's clear
with regard to the member qualifications
I can tell you just a little bit of the
very very deep history of this
um the the term
um where the the statute says refers to
the attorney member license to practice
in New Hampshire
that was actually the in the second
draft or the first draft of the original
legislation long before the legislature
got it and it was in the second draft
that the the other potential member
qualifications were introduced so
professional engineer which is a
recognized term of Law and land surveyor
so it said it can be either a
professional engineer or land surveyor
um recognize though that professional
engineer is already a term of law so you
don't need to say professional land
surveyor because for a land surveyor to
be claiming to be a land surveyor in New
Hampshire they have to be a professional
lands Affair it's redundant I don't
think that's that's necessary it's not a
big deal it's it's harmless but I think
unnecessary
um with regard to
um
the temporary member appointments this
language was taken directly out of the
btla statute the board of tax on land
appeals and that statute's been in
existence since 1973 and this the entire
uh structure of the housing appeals
board statute
was uh significantly built upon the
existing language that we have in RSA
71b which is the btla statute so the
temporary member appointment language
that you see in the existing statute for
the housing appeals board is what has
existed since 1973 for the btla
so I don't think that that the change is
necessary although I recognize
representative Lynn's expertise in court
matters I think we all recognize that
but I think that if we're going to
change one we should probably be
changing the other statute as well
I'll pass out the letter just recognize
that it part ports of it parts of it are
no longer relevant um as long as you
take up the amendment I'd be happy to
take any questions
any questions for Mr Frost
thank you thank you
thank you
Chris Norwood
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
provide testimony my name is Chris
Norwood I am a realtor in the state of
New Hampshire and the 2022 chair of the
New Hampshire Association of Realtors
public policy committee I speak today to
urge you to in expedient to legislate
this bill the housing appeals board is
something and we'll talk further about
this in the next bill that we feel is
very valuable to the state of New
Hampshire
specifically to HB 1254 we have not seen
the amendment I just would offer up some
high-level thoughts
relative to the uh the planning board
member I share some of Senator Guida's
concerns that was echoed I Believe by
Ben Frost and the piece I would just say
relative to the vacancy part of the
value in our opinion to the housing
appeals board not only for
um
a a potential land owner but also to the
municipalities is the speed in which uh
decisions are renders uh and that that
includes actually having the hearings
and so forth so I would just hope that
the um the amended language
provides with uh provides a balance
between that expediency and some of the
concerns that the sponsor has of the
bill relative to some challenges perhaps
in the appointment process again just
the speed of the housing appeals board
does alleviate costs not only for
um
the the developer but municipalities
there's legal costs charged every single
uh you know time that these appeals go
on and on so thank you for your
testimony and happy to answer any
questions
are there any questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
Mr chair
Alyssa Margolis
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Alyssa
margolin and I am it's okay
hey sorry I'm the director of housing
action New Hampshire we're a Statewide
Coalition of 80 organizations and
businesses United around affordable
housing policy and ending homelessness
in New Hampshire we are opposed to House
Bill 1254. I'm sharing with you a letter
similar to others we had not had a
chance to review the amendment so a lot
of uh what is referenced in there
is no longer germane but our position
Remains the Same and as I had a chance
to briefly look at this before
testifying I can mention a couple of
things um one I want to start with just
saying by that I think we really share
um the the bill sponsors desire to
educate
um the legislature about the um the need
for the housing appeals board and to
bring some kind of closure to what had
been a divisive debate
um and I see this opportunity today and
these hearings
um to really address some of these
concerns
clarify the origins of the board as we
as we heard from Senator gaida and
really debunked some of the myths that
have been circulating I do want to share
with you that housing action New
Hampshire which is mostly known for its
affordable housing Focus was just one of
a larger group of stakeholders and and
you've uh you know you've heard from
some of them today
the bill was originally proposed back in
discussions had started in 2017 and
Senate Bill 557
it was followed by Senate Bill 306 and
House Bill 104 in 2019 and then the
housing appeals board was established
when RSA 679 took effect in July 2020
. I mentioned the history only because I
think one of the myths is that the house
did not have a chance to address the
need for the board and it did several
times
one in-house Bill 104 and again when the
budget came back to the house during
that debate
in terms you know obviously we we share
the concern and and
um and underscore the need for strong
conflict of interest policy
we think that RSA 697 or 679 rather
already does that
um and as Ben Frost has noted this
conflict of interest policy is pulled
directly from other conflicts of
interest policies particularly the one
that governs the Bureau of tax and land
appeals and many of uh issues like venue
chains and procedures came from that
board which has been operating
successfully in our state since the mid
70s
overall I would say as you consider what
to do uh with with this particular bill
I would say to consider that we really
don't need to make these tweaks at this
time this issue was deliberated over
three years we have a successful model
it's just starting as was noted by
representative Alexander earlier and we
think it would be more prudent for the
legislature to wait three to five years
then perhaps request a report and
convene a study committee and then look
at what tweaks you think are appropriate
I'm happy to take any questions
any questions for MS margolin
see none thank you
and is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 1254.
seeing no one will close the hearing on
House Bill 1254.
and move on
to our next hearing that's on House Bill
1216.
this is repealing the housing appeals
board
the primary sponsor is
representative Boyd is representative
Boyd here
thank you and there I have to say we
have about uh
10 people who have signed up to speak
actually more than that at this point in
time so if you could make your testimony
succinct that would be great
you can get the you could just testify
and get your card in later and be fine
my apologies Mr chairman
thank you
through through you to the to my
esteemed colleagues of the court general
court my name is Bill Boyd representing
Hillsborough 21 in Merrimack
I'm here to speak in support of House
Bill 1216 to repeal the housing appeals
board
as a former local Town official having
sat on the Town Council on the plain
board in my own community of Merrimack
for a combination of close to 20 years I
take a lot of pride in what what we've
done at the local level in terms of our
our ability to appropriately manage land
use gross growth in our community
I certainly am sympathetic
in understanding that some other
communities may not have the a balanced
approach in developing land use policies
that would benefit the people that live
in their communities and the developers
that choose to build in those
communities
they seek to repeal the housing appeals
board because historically
the bill was presented as a writer in
the house budget it was never vetted at
the legislative legislative level and as
a as a you know having served my
community locally now you know I take
the will of the voters very seriously as
I'm sure all of you do and I feel that
the
desire to enact the housing appeals
board undermine the will of the voters
in New Hampshire in terms of how they
want to self-determine how they want to
grow and choose to grow their
communities
now I unders I do recognize the fact
that the Superior Courts are overwhelmed
with cases and I and I do I do respect
that and I certainly understand having
and knowing the developers that have
presented in the town of Merrimack that
time is money and the longer that you're
waiting to get a decision on a case is
more money that they're losing out of
their pockets in terms of the ability to
a bill the project and be
recoup a profit
um
in the process of wanting to create a
level of nimbleness you've added a layer
of bureaucracy to the process that
potentially could add more time to a
land to a land use issue
the suggestion if I'm choosing to repeal
I need to bring you an alternative and
the alternative is to consider creating
a dedicated land court with one single
Justice dedicated to and deal with land
use issues petitions to quiet title
property disputes between two people
landlord-tenant issues it would present
a unique opportunity to create the level
of Gravitas at the at that particular
level which the state of New Hampshire
has always relied upon the Superior
Court to be the final say on on land use
issues it would give a financial excuse
me not Financial excuse me it would give
a final
decision to the to to the respondents in
the case of how a decision is going to
come about regarding
a particular an issue that appears as it
relates to land use so that would be my
suggestion is to repeal the housing
appeals board and consider enacting and
creating a land use Court dedicated to
those specific topics
I have no written testimony I'd be happy
to answer any questions
any questions for representative Boyd
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Mr chairman to you and the committee
members thank you for hearing me
senator gaida
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record Bob Guida Senate District 2.
speaking in opposition to the repeal of
the housing appeals board
first to some comments made by the
preceding speaker
with respect to this bill not having had
a vetting in the House and Senate let me
reiterate
the succession of legislative events
that took place
Senate passed Senate Bill 557
the original legislation in March of
2000 of 2018.
the house recommended a bill for interim
study in a division vote on April 26 of
18 then recommended the bill for future
legislation
in a vote of 20 to 2.
hardly controversial
myself Senator Rosenwald Senator Carson
felt this Fuller Clark Waters
representative Butler walner
representative hinch and representative
Porter reintroduced the board in the
2019 session in Senate bill 306.
the house version of the housing appeals
board was introduced by Lynn Ober
representative over in House Bill 104
and the stakeholders urged support for
the Senate version of the housing
appeals board legislation
so the house bill was itl'd on January
31st of 2019 with a Voice vote
the senate election law Municipal
Affairs committee recommended Senate
Bill 306 ought to pass
it was then heard in Senate Finance to
received an ought to pass 6-0
final the Senate passed it in a roll
call vote of 18 to 5. clearly strongly
supported
Senator dalessandro then chair of the
finance committee and the Senate
requested at be tabled and addressed
within the budget I oppose that of
course I was not in the majority and so
there was put into the at the trailer
bill
it was discussed by conferees during the
committee's a conference for the 2021
budget they agreed to the request that
the appropriation for the housing
appeals board moved to fiscal 21 and its
appropriation of 415 thousand dollars
included in the final Vision a final
version of House Bill 4 because House
Bill 2 had been vetoed by the governor
so that's that sort of lays out that
this was not hidden in the cover of
Darkness this thing has been heard both
in the house and in the Senate and in
fact in the house recommended for
appropriate legislation
the reason is
this board was was put together was
because we had towns around the state
with all due respect to my preceding
speaker okay in which planning boards
weaponized the legal system
and by pleadings and motions and
hearings in an already overloaded Court
okay cause delays which then would
result in investors
stating I don't want to spend my money
on litigation I want an investment or I
don't want to wait another two years
until this is decided and would withdraw
their support thereby killing support
for Workforce housing projects in the
state this is not low-income housing
this is Workforce housing clearly
defined in statute
and there by exacerbating the problem of
the housing shortage we are still
experiencing at a crisis level today
so the bill passed
and uh I am always a believer that look
to data for your answer as to the
question of whether or not this board
should continue
so I sent I had my assistant send to
each of you or perhaps to your secretary
and ends to each of you last night the
link to the housing appeals Board
website and the link to the cases and
the decisions right and when you read
these decisions you'll find that in the
15 that are rendered 13 found in favor
of the developer
two actually found in favor of the
communities planning process
and those decisions three major issues
were revealed first planning boards were
violating the workforce housing statutes
for the state not optional state law
second they were violating their own
ordinances
in making arbitrary decisions based on
heaven knows what
and third they were making it up as they
were going along without any statutory
or ordinance to support the decisions
they were making relative to Developers
okay
that is this housing appeals board does
not challenge local control
it enforces it
nobody in a legislative position and
this state is above the law and that
includes planning boards and zoning
boards of adjustment
the planning boards were hot against
this bill they hate it
the fact of the matter is the results
each to which each of you have access to
read and I invite you to do so clearly
show a pattern
where this board is doing its job
helping solve the problem within the
context of the existing laws
and helping helping to cure the problem
of Workforce housing that is really a
critical issue in our state
I would ask you to itl this bill
it was modeled after the board of tax
and land appeals which functions very
well
okay it is doing its job as evidenced by
the results of its work
and I would invite you to discuss with
any of the members of the board
you know their jobs what they're doing
how they see their functions
but based upon the results I would ask
you to itl this repeal of the housing
appeals board thank you Mr chairman
and I'll take any questions questions
for the senator
representative nodder thank you Mr
chairman thank you senator for taking
the question this out of curiosity could
you tell me who the five senators were
who were against the bill
I don't remember been too long
I'd be happy to find that out for you
though thank you
any other questions for Senator gaida
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony today thank you Mr chairman
next person to call is Daniel pray
ER
you need to turn on your microphone just
like that yep
yep my name is Daniel pray from Amherst
New Hampshire I serve as and I'm
probably going to be in the minority
here I serve as a zoning Board member in
my town I am also a selectman
I also have a law degree and I've been
attending my planning board meetings for
the past two and a half years so I have
a very broad knowledge of how the hab
like many other like several other
communities we had an appeal before the
hab
and I just want to tell you the results
of that because we are probably the
first to my knowledge who are trying to
appeal that to the Supreme Court which
is another issue
I want to take exception to ours is not
a Workforce housing appeal by the way
I'm going to put that out there I think
the previous speaker is intimating that
these are all Workforce housing and
somehow there's some vast conspiracy
among planning board members
to not allow Workforce housing if I'll
probably I hope there's other members
here from zbas or playing boards because
I wanted to spell that myth I take my
job very seriously as I do as I know the
planning board does our appeal in town
is a planning board decision
I
the previous speaker mentioned that 13
cases were
the town decision playing board and
Zoning Board was overturned
I think you ought to take a look at
those decisions or maybe not because I
don't think you can really tell I think
you need to speak to your zoning board
or planning board what does it what
decision went before them let me give
you a brief a very brief idea of what
happened in my town
there were two issues that went before
the housing appeals board
they should the standard of review
should be
did that board have the the evidence
before them to reach that decision
Amherst decision from the hab doesn't
follow that standard of review they say
they do but they don't one of them was a
federal law question our planning board
was given
advice from Town Council
that that case would not
it would violate federal law the
planning board was given that
information and relied on it Hab came
back
the case slot was cited first off in the
footnote the hab said
oh that that's about two buildings that
doesn't even apply
file we file for a motion for
reconsideration and explained why that
federal law case was important came back
the motion for reconsideration was
denied as well
well we looked at that federal case and
no we don't see we don't see that
happening that's not the standard review
did the planning board have
Knowledge from their Town Council that
that federal law applied yes they did
the hab's not in charge of federal law
they're only need they are only supposed
to be looking at does the planning board
have that knowledge given all the other
evidence all the abutters that testified
this this case went on there were
continuances by the applicant so that
was one that was one of our issues was
the federal law so this had over said no
go back to go back to the planning board
work it out work it out with with the
applicant
the other issue was a rural aesthetic
that the Supreme Court in this state has
acknowledged over many many many years
that towns have a right to preserve
their rural aesthetic
it was denied the site plan the
subdivision site plan was denied on that
on that condition
that rural aesthetic is determined at
the site plan stage
in the regulations is determined at the
site plan stage the ham went back to a
conditional use permit that the
applicant was granted two years prior
and made up their own definition of real
aesthetic they said Amherst did not have
a definition of rural aesthetic we have
things in our in our regulations that I
would disagree and then went back to a
conditional use permit and said
you agreed to rural back then even
though it wasn't even considered at the
conditional use permit so my point to
all this is there are there are probably
other decisions I know this case
intimately so I can speak to it if you
go back to your zoning boards and
planning boards talk to them about it
talk to them about the decision I know
there are towns who did not decide to
appeal because it was a money issue as a
selective in my town that was a big
concern how much is this going to cost
us but it was a bad decision we had no
choice
now I'll get to the appeal part
so everybody thinks oh you can appeal it
to the Supreme Court sure you can
we just found out it's rule 10 they
don't have to take it we don't even know
if we're going to get heard in front of
the justices so one attorney that makes
up this Hab and two other people who are
involved in the real estate develop
field
made a determination on our legal case
they're not trained in the law they
don't know legal analysis and that is an
appellate position what do they know
about case law in New Hampshire
they don't
um we
you need to fix it I think the I think
some amendments if you don't repeal it
some amendments that were offered the
previous bill
uh I would add there should be a zoning
board or planning board member part of
this commission they're the ones who for
years sit every month in your towns and
listen and follow the ordinances they're
not making up things as they go I would
take exception to that that's making the
zoning board and Boogeyman in every town
in this state the boogeyman because
there is an affordable housing that's
your issue to solve
there there's always been an appeal
process available Workforce housing
builders remedy six months what changed
six months that's pretty quick
but bad decisions coming from a
um
a Hab where there's one attorney who by
the way worked for Real Estate
developers it's it's pretty clear to me
that the makeup of this is not what it
should be we should be entitled to have
something in front of a judge someone
who knows legal analysis and can
interpret the law and and tell you
yeah Tyler you didn't do this right I
think and it's kind of interesting I
don't know the statistics if I had time
I would have done it I was going to go
back 20 or 30 years and look at the
superior court and Supreme Court cases
where towns were upheld I bet it's a
complete flip of what we're seeing now
if those are that's before judges that's
before The Supreme Court and the
superior court so don't go by this 13 or
15. talk to those towns talk to those
planning boards and those zoning boards
and find out where those decisions are
wrong because I know there's people that
say that's wrong but we just can't
afford to go on
so that's my testimony thank you for
listening and hopefully you'll make some
changes if you don't repeal it I would
repeal it I liked representative Boyd's
suggestion that you make this on land
core it is someone that is trained in
the law knows legal analysis specific to
those issues so if you do not repeal it
I would I would encourage you immensely
to go that route and the other changes
from the previous
bill I
I would encourage you to if you don't do
any of that but a zoning someone who has
practice on a zoning board or a planning
board for years in this town to put on
this on this board because right now
um your talents are not represented and
that means your constituents aren't
representative all the citizens in your
town who rely on they voted for those
ordinances
so it even goes further back than your
your town zoning boards and planning
boards U.S constituents are not
represented this is costing them more
this is costing My Town more because we
have to appeal it and we don't even know
if we're going to get before The Supreme
Court so
all right enough we got too many people
to talk well then does anybody have any
questions for Ms pray
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
we are uh
a little bit pressed for time I just
note that I tend to alternate between
pros and cons and I have one more person
who's speaking in favor and nine people
who are speaking against so
um
I'm just saying that because if you're
one of those people speaking against I'm
not sure we need to put on all that much
more weight so
and in the event uh Dave Juve
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is David I'm a senior vice
president for the business and industry
Association and for the next three weeks
serving as its interim president I'm
here in strong opposition to this bill
the issue of Workforce housing is a key
issue for employers throughout the state
please find this bill in expedient I'm
happy to answer any questions
I'm doing my part to move this along
you're doing you're doing terrific so
are there any questions
the questions might okay the probably
the question will take longer than the
testimony go ahead representative wolper
thank you Mr chairman I will be brief
could you just just briefly say why
Workforce housing as opposed to is
something that
why you are thinking why the hab is so
important for Workforce housing yeah
it's an issue for the Bia because it's a
significant issue for our members from
around the state business is larger and
small have indicated to us they're
having a hard time finding employees and
retaining employees because there is
insufficient place for these individuals
to live within proximity of the
workplace
foreign
so what does the hab add to how does
that alleviate your issue we believe one
of the reasons that there's insufficient
work for uh Workforce housing around the
state is because of decisions that are
made at the local level that do not
comply or follow in the spirit of state
law or case law in New Hampshire
up until the creation of the housing
appeals board the only recourse a
developer had was to take that town to
court which is both expensive and time
consuming the sponsor of the bill
alluded mentioned that he thought the
hab the housing appeals board was an
additional bureaucracy I would say it's
an alternative bureaucracy it's designed
to give the developer a quick fast
appeals process without having to go to
court
other questions
see none thank you Mr Dubai
Jonah wheeler
I'm not sure um
if I've got the correct name
uh was supporting the bill
Ben Frost
thank you Mr chairman I'll do my best to
be well not quite as brief as my friend
Dave Gervais but I'll do my best Ben
Frost from New Hampshire housing I'm
here to speak in opposition with the
bill and I have another letter which I
will distribute
it's been
uh
the housing situation of the state's
been talked a lot about and about the
details are in the letter I'll let you
see that for yourselves we all know that
there's a crisis of housing Supply the
housing appeals board was conceived of
as
part of a solution to that not not a
Panacea but a measure that the state
could take to help improve the housing
Supply and this really reflects the
notion that I believe is true that there
was a latent demand for appeals of local
decisions on housing and Housing
Development
appeals that were not being made because
of the the time and cost that is
involved in making those appeals when
you go to Superior Court the housing
appeals board meets that by creating a
faster less expensive in many cases
alternative to Superior Court that
applies the same legal standards as are
used by the courts
and that is that is covered in the in
the letter that have submitted to you
um I would reiterate what Senator gaida
said please read the decisions of the
housing appeals board these are
um they reflect careful analysis and a
balanced approach that neither favors
one side nor the other the fact that
they come down the majority of have them
the majority of them have come down in
favor of developers I think is simply
indicative of the fact that these are
the people who are bringing the appeals
right now but
um what you get with the housing appeal
sport that you would not get with a land
use court or a land use docket is the
time the quickness of decisions the
flexibility of making the appeals such
as the The Rules of Evidence which like
the btla Do Not Apply in the housing
appeals board courts are really much
tighter in in what uh evidence can be
presented although these are just like
the courts heard on the record
non-attorney representation is permitted
in the housing appeals board you can't
have your engineer or your surveyor
representing you in court in court but
you can in the housing appeals board
likewise municipalities if they want to
represent themselves in in the housing
appeals board they can have their their
Town planner do that if they want to
they don't have to have the town
attorney
presenting their case this really
represents a a presents a lower cost of
access to justice for Developers for
anyone who's exercising their rights
before a local board including a Butters
too a Butters can bring a case before
the housing appeals board
it's an easier place to get to Justice
ultimately the housing appeals board is
about holding governmental bodies
accountable for their actions and I say
that as as the chairman of my own Town's
planning board I'm not speaking for the
planning board that's but that's a
position I hold uh in the Town of Warner
uh it's a position I take very seriously
and I I can tell you I'm not worried
about the housing appealsport speaking
as the chairman of my Town's planning
board I feel confident in the decisions
that we make because I know that we're
applying the law
are applying our our rules uh
even-handedly to everyone who comes
before us and if someone chooses to
appeal a decision to the housing appeals
board that my board makes fine we'll
take the consequences uh and that's okay
with me
um I've been a professional planner for
35 years advising communities I've been
an attorney
representing municipalities and Advising
municipalities for 25 years I see this
as a real win for everyone for the the
Developers for the property owners who
are trying to exercise their rights
before local boards
for the butters who want to have their
their their say and their day before an
impartial tribunal and for the public
and for the people of New Hampshire
this is a good board and should be
preserved I'll be happy to take any
questions
any questions for Mr Frost
thank you for your testimony
Ellen Grove
uh good afternoon Mr chairman and
committee members thank you for the
opportunity to speak I do have written
testimony as well
uh as I said I'm Ellen grow I am the
executive director of the Concord
coalition to end homelessness and I'm
here to speak in opposition to this bill
beyond the workflow Workforce housing
that it affects it affects the housing
that our agency is trying to create
so the Concord coalition to end
homelessness is a non-profit
organization we provide a lot of Crisis
services for people who are homeless
including a daytime Resource Center a
winter shelter Outreach Services and all
of those crisis services are really
important but none of them actually end
homelessness it's permanent housing that
ends homelessness and the housing crisis
that New Hampshire is having right now
is having a devastating impact on our
ability to move people from homelessness
into permanent housing
so one of the things that our agency has
been increasingly focused on in the last
several years is um is our permanent
housing permanent Supportive Housing
Programs where we can provide rental
assistance to people coming from
homelessness along with ongoing case
management support to help people stay
stably housed most of the people that we
serve have disability income as their
only income so they're so they need that
rental assistance and they need that
support to stay housed right now we have
about six people who have rental
vouchers in their hands that they could
rent an apartment and it's probably been
six months of looking they cannot find a
place to use that rental voucher and if
they do find an available apartment it's
often the rent is too high the voucher
won't cover it so we we are in a
desperate situation for more affordable
housing a couple of years ago we stepped
our feet into affordable housing
development our ourselves even though
we're very small agency and we converted
a downtown office building in Concord
into four one-bedroom apartments for
people coming from homelessness and
they're occupied now the people are very
happy in their new homes we had to get
several variances for that project and
we went before our zoning board and they
were all granted
um if if those if that had been appealed
and the process dragged on it wouldn't
wouldn't have affected a profit to us it
would have killed our project we don't
have the finances to to uh go through a
protracted legal battle our funding
sources we get a lot of subsidized
funding sources to do our work and those
have deadlines on them those it would
have killed our project
we're about to embark on our second
project to create eight units in Concord
again for people coming from long-term
homelessness and one of the reasons that
we feel confident going ahead is that we
know that if there is a zoning appeal by
either us or the um or the uh the other
side that it will be that is a
a process that's predictable and fast so
that we can have the confidence to make
the Investments that we have to make to
go forward with surveys and everything
else it's a costly process and it would
be out of our reach if
we really need this to keep it um to
make this all work to get the housing we
need for people who are homeless so that
I have more in the letter that you can
read I'm trying to be brief if you have
any questions happy to answer them
okay any questions where Miss grow yes
representative nodder thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question
um what do you think of converting an
old hotel into individual tiny homes
I think it has a lot of Promise There's
issues with it as well
um it's a little bit off topic from this
perhaps but um they're doing that in a
lot of larger cities and I think there's
a lot of promise to that idea
follow up I mentioned it because
listening to your testimony um you were
talking about the housing shortage and
all that and this is something I
discussed with someone a couple weeks
ago I just wanted to run it by yeah no
there's a lot of promise to that there's
a lot of different ways people are going
about it in different cities
um you know there's issues that have to
be dealt with a lot of times but it but
there's a lot of promise for sure
other questions
seeing them thank you thank you very
much thank you for your testimony
uh Alyssa margolin
hopefully I got it
better this time
foreign
for the record my name is Alyssa marglin
I serve as director of housing action
New Hampshire a Statewide Coalition of
80 organizations United around
affordable housing and ending
homelessness we'd like to express our
opposition to house bill
1216. as I noted before we do see this
as an opportunity to address concerns
and debunk some of those myths I know
that um
uh you want to move your hearing along
Mr chairman so I just want to focus on
something I did not address in the prior
hearing
um I do want to talk about the fact that
this housing appeals board was really
designed specifically not to have any
impact on local control it was
specifically designed to provide that
fast review subject matter expertise but
only after local reviews are exhausted
and that language can be found in RSA
679 colon 5 Roman numeral four
in fact the review board only has
concurrent jurisdiction with the Syria
Superior Court it was even noted in a
legislative bulletin from the New
Hampshire Municipal Association that
read the board applies the same law and
same standards that a judge would apply
so municipality would not be prejudiced
by having an appeal brought to the board
rather than to the court a couple of
other uh key key myths to address a
housing appeals board cannot rewrite
local zoning it cannot change
subdivision rigs or site plan regulation
stations or change your local master
plan or change the rules of your
Conservation Commission or your historic
district commission it cannot impose its
own view of planning it can't can't be
urge you to go in a smart growth
Direction it simply reviews specific
cases according to established laws and
ordinances just like Superior Court it's
faster it's therefore less expensive and
it comes with expertise
um this uh opportunity to avoid a
lengthy costly litigation
helps local landowners also they can
represent themselves per se in fact at a
recent presentation by the housing
appeals board they said they just had
their first prosec case and it went well
so arguably in enhancing
local property rights and opportunities
for local property owners
that who want to take up issues
impacting their private property they
too can access fast review of their
cases at much less expense the final
myth I just want to address is that that
somehow this housing appeals appeals
board is is in favor of the developers
it's only in favor of the law as
established it applies the same
standards for case review finally board
seats are not political appointments
they are appointed by the Supreme Court
um
and so uh I think I'll conclude it there
and be happy to take any questions
any questions for Miss marklin
thank you for your testimony today
next person is Nick Norman
thank you thank you again for speaking I
can be very brief
the landlord Community will support
anything that
um
we're in favor of making better movement
towards more affordable housing we feel
the appeals board is a step towards
creating more affordable housing we
would not want to see it repealed
everything that I've heard today
supports
continuing and letting this play out
I'm done
any questions for Mr Norman
seeing none thank you thank you for your
brief testimony
and Chris Norwood
good afternoon again Mr chair members of
the committee Chris Norwood the 2022
public policy chair for the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors a few
brief points
um when this went through the
legislative process and it was passed
there were municipalities that were in
favor and so I'd like to dispel the
myths that this is developers versus
municipalities there were municipalities
who testified in favor because of the
expediency and the cost savings that
they would incur as well
um I would also you know we talked about
uh hearing these cases reading through
these cases uh furthering what uh
Senator Guida had said a number of these
cases were um sent back to the
municipalities for a re-hearing so I
also want to make sure that there's not
this this concept that there's this uh
Invisible Hand of government uh that is
taking over a planning board's decisions
no in some cases it's saying hey the
town said this is the land use code that
we wanted to adhere to and to put it in
my words not the housing appeal Birds
words uh the the local uh government
body went rogue and uh went against the
will of the voters that established uh
the various uh planning zoning
ordinances within their town so they
they asked for a re-hearing or ask
excuse me the housing appeals board
asked that the town have a re-hearing
we've talked a lot about Workforce
housing I just want to clarify this is
for all how housing not just Workforce
housing and the last thing I would just
say is that I do think that the current
makeup of the housing appeals board is
appropriate you having a lawyer and then
a a civil engineer or a land surveyor
and then it's someone who's learned it
in land use and or development I think
that that is a higher standard than the
the current makeup of most planning
boards and zoning boards which is uh
which is appropriate for an appellate
body so I thank you for allowing me the
testimony
questions for Mr Norwood
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else who'd like to
testify on House Bill 1216 yes sir
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the board my name is John Cronin I'm an
attorney from Manchester I've been in
the land use business for over 30 years
I spent about two or three weeks nights
a week at different zoning and planning
boards and I'm opposed to this
legislation I think the housing appeals
board is a great tool not only for
developers and landowners but also for
communities
uh anyone that spent time in the
superior court and probably had hundreds
of cases and land use and appeals in the
Superior Court they do a great job
they're very busy but the way these
cases are presented are by offer of
proof and a record and when I started in
the 80s your subdivision and site plan
regulations might be a few pages
today they're complex they're like books
they're very difficult to manage and
it's rare to find one of our Superior
Court judges no matter how smart they
are they'd ever spent a moment in a zba
or a planning board
and they're getting these cases to
presented to them on appeal through some
records with no live testimony it's very
difficult if not impossible for them and
I think if you talk to the Superior
Court judges many of them would tell you
that their least favorite cases are land
use appeals because they simply don't
have the subject matter expertise
I've had a number of cases and have
others pending up at the appeals board
you have three people that have lived
the business of land use they understand
what the record looks like they
understand the engineering data and they
can make informed decisions not to
substitute their judgment for the local
boards and all of them are well
intentioned people volunteer time for
the most part they do their best but
it's an overwhelming task for them to
understand it and to confront the
pressures that they have from some of
their community members to prevent
development but not in my backyard the
social media communities I certainly
agree with Mr Frost that this is not a
Panacea appearing in the Massachusetts
land Court that's a great resource I'd
love to see one in New Hampshire I
recognize it's very expensive and
probably will not happen in my career I
also have strong opinions about home
rule and some of the ways that many of
our land use boards do their business
most don't have the benefit of the
speakers we had before Miss Craig I
believe and Mr Frost who are trained
professionals and probably are the leads
in their respective boards but for today
it would be a shame to displace this
board and I think what the legislature
should be looking at is maybe to have a
Statewide land use board maybe for a fee
that developers can get in and out from
start to finish because right now the
cost of development is so expensive and
the longer you delay the process those
costs get stuck back to the homeowner or
the buyer and they make what might be
affordable unaffordable if you can get
into a process do your engineering
present it to an informed tribunal and
get out many of these contracts for
these housing projects they're subject
to approvals and usually you have six
months maybe a year to get it done you
can't get out of the Superior Court in a
year right now if I file today I might
get a structuring conference and 90 or
120 days and that's what the statutory
priority already please don't change the
housing appeals board love to see it
made better and to have some other
Statewide resources so that we can build
the housing we need thanks
hold on
are there any questions for attorney
Cronin
none thank you thank you thank you for
coming today
anyone else want to testify
yes sir
and Mr crony need to submit your card
before you before you leave okay
thank you Mr chairman I have a card for
you which I'll submit my name is Ari
Pollock I'm an attorney with the
Gallagher Ferb in Concord I'm also a
registered lobbyist for the New
Hampshire Home Builders and we're here
in opposition to the bill and to the
repeal we simply want to add our voice
to the chorus you've heard today from
some pretty impressive folks who have
worked on this subject matter for
several years now the home builders are
certainly an involved stakeholder and
feel similarly to the others that have
testified today I think it was almost a
year ago exactly that I testified in
opposition to a prior repeal Bill all
the reasons remain the same the housing
appeals board serves an important
function it serves an efficient function
and it serves a subject matter expertise
function all of which are difficult to
find in Superior Court if this bill were
to pass and the housing appeals board
were to be repealed all these cases
would simply go to an already overworked
Superior Court they won't disappear and
so I would ask you when considering the
fiscal note and the potential savings
it's simply going to be redeployment of
that money in other places there's no
savings to be had there's a question of
whether or not you can obtain more
efficient Justice in another area that
would address the housing crisis that
the state faces thanks very much for
listening
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions of Mr Pollock
seeing none thank you my pleasure thank
you
and Alan Carpenter
thank you Mr chair my name is Alan
Carpenter from Windham New Hampshire I
represent myself this afternoon from a
qualifications I'm a multi-term member
and chair of the Wyndham planning board
and the board of Selectmen over the last
25 years and I served for a half a dozen
years on the Rockingham Planning
Commission
I guess I'm a bit of a minority I'm
asking you to support and move forward
this bill
and after listening to everyone prior to
me I'll take two different perspectives
and I can be very brief want it more of
a twenty thousand foot View and the
other aboard a 2 000 foot view the 20
000 foot view is simple I know we're not
as red as we used to be
but I'd like to think we are still New
Hampshire
and I know in the 21st century Live Free
or Die maybe doesn't carry the same
moniker that it did 200 years ago
but we're still about communities having
control over their own land use running
their own municipalities with as little
interference from other governments as
possible
and this housing appeals board in its
short-lived history is the antithesis of
that this is more of a an excuse the
term but a New Jersey or New York or
Massachusetts type structure in my view
than it is a New Hampshire item
we pass our ordinances in town
we present them to the voters they vote
on them they pass them and we as a
planning board execute them we've seen
decisions come back from the hab not
because we didn't understand our
ordinances and I'll get to that in a
second but frankly because of a very
myopic and very excuse the term but
biased view as we've heard they're
developers they're lawyers who make
their livings from developers they have
a very land owners rights perspective
and I'm not saying that's a bad thing
but again I think philosophically the
legislature has to decide do you want to
do our zoning from Concord or do you
want to let the communities decide how
do we evolve and develop their towns
because to date what we've seen from the
hab and somebody mentioned the 13 to 2 I
think that really just says it all is is
not something that's adding any value to
the communities now I was also not aware
and I thank you for the previous
testimony
that really this isn't about the housing
appeals board this is about Workforce
housing
and I would submit to you as one who's
lived with Workforce housing since it
was passed here in Concord that it's a
well-intentioned
but significantly flawed RSA
and I think that's evidence by all these
appeals coming in around Workforce
housing if Workforce housing is broke
let's fix it
let's not add a bureaucratic layer in
the middle
of our representative voters and our
Judiciary trying to fix a problem that
we actually created let's fix the
problem
and I can tell you as a planning board
member we don't struggle to interpret
our ordinances they're very clear to us
we wrote them in many cases
we do struggle interpreting the RSA
around Workforce housing in the
vagueness of it in many areas I fully
support and I'm on record in my planning
board meetings in saying that we need
and certainly windham's a prime example
of this we need diversity in our housing
stock
but the current ordinance doesn't allow
us to do that
as clearly and concisely as we would
like to in many cases so I think there's
opportunity there and that that's where
your efforts would be best spent not
creating this third level of bureaucracy
in between you know the net Ned is
in the last 250 years we seem to get by
pretty well without the hab
I know some folks talked about the
expediency
and I understand I've built for profit
in my own past I understand the idea of
time is money and to a developer that's
important I will tell you to your
communities
speed is not necessarily a friend we're
much more interested in a well thought
out well-constructed decision that
reflects the will of the voters in our
community and is good for the community
then we are getting a fast decision
and so far what we've seen from the hav
is expedient
but it's not necessarily as well
constructed that would allow us at least
to move forward so I thank you for
listening today and I appreciate on I'm
sure I don't really have any questions
but should I
yeah any questions for Mr Carpenter oh
excellent
yes representative Lorenzo thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Carpenter I
just have a short question and I wanted
to know what you meant by New Hampshire
being a red state
well the the monikers of red versus blue
we have a 100 Year history of being a
very Republican state and today we are
certainly not
furthermore I wanted to know
what you meant when you said that New
Hampshire is not New Jersey or New York
or Massachusetts or Connecticut well
I've lived in New York and New Jersey
for decades of my life and they're the
everything from land use frankly up
through was legislated very uh
distinctly from Trenton and from Albany
the local communities had very little
control over most aspects of their
communities lives I've been in New
Hampshire now for 20
four years and have enjoyed it being
just the opposite where Concord sits up
here and does a lot of great things for
the the communities but that we
basically get to run our own show if I
may be so casual
thank you oh thank you for your question
are there any other questions for Mr
Carpenter
seeing none thank you for listening
testimony and I think that concludes the
testimony on House Bill 1216 and I'll
declare the hearing closed
uh just looking at um
committee members do you do you need a
break are you ready to move forward
huh
if uh if we could just have five minutes
till half past and that will give
everybody an opportunity just to have a
brief break
recess until half past
three
all right
nice to meet you thank you dear Mr
Clinton
I think I need to head tomorrow I have a
meeting to get through at home and I'd
rather than waiting you know for the
hearing you go 10 minutes and then go
you're not gonna go with the break
so I will see you tomorrow
we're about to go
into room oh my gosh good for you
take care
yeah
I still live in the same house I got two
houses
we have one on the river and one
downtown yeah
it's down on the penny okay
well you go in off the highway and
I know foreign
oh yeah yeah
supposedly retired
University of
the video I think he still speaks they
won't give it up
stop points the chairs stick out
his mind sticks out
that was John Crone an Old Testament
Chicago committee house Judiciary
Committee back to order
our next item of business is a hearing
on House Bill 1200 relative to notice of
rent increases in residential rental
property
and the primary sponsor is
representative Conley
and
welcome to the committee
thank you very much Mr chairman I am
Casey Conway state representative from
Dover representing Stratford County
District 13. it's a district that is
primarily rental housing
this version you have today HB 1200 is
sort of a modified simpler clearer
version of a rent notification bill that
you have seen
I guess the last two years
so what this would do is require
landlords to provide 45 days notice for
an increase in rent the current
requirement is 30 days and for some
context that's the same standard already
used in Maine and it's 15 days fewer
than is required in Vermont
the community excuse me the committee
has heard it before but the housing
crisis in the state is real and it's
gotten worse during the pandemic rents
have increased faster than inflation in
every county in the state the average
two-bedroom apartment now costs fifteen
hundred dollars
and just for contacts the first time I
came before this committee the average
two bedroom was about twelve hundred and
fifty dollars so that's two years ago
um
in Dover uh just as contacts fifteen
hundred dollars would get you I think
zero two-bedroom apartments so it's uh
it's substantially higher in some parts
of the state
the vacancy rate is less than one
percent it's as low as half a percent or
even lower
there just aren't many rentals available
at any price point
the net effect of this Dynamic is that
someone who's priced out of one
apartment
cannot necessarily find another
apartment nearby in the same town in the
same city and certainly not expect to
find it in the same neighborhood
so the ramification of that is uh you
could have to change jobs you might not
have access to Transportation your kids
could need a new school district you
might lose access to child care it's not
just moving from one place to another
and furthermore
um you know in a state with an
employment crisis if somebody
is forced to move out of state we've
lost not only a resident we've lost
probably a worker who
may not come back so
you know and just as a point of context
this is not an anti-landlord Bill we had
the I guess the pleasure and displeasure
of becoming landlords this summer we
rented our house out for four months so
we saw the extreme interest
overwhelming interest in the home and
then we saw the problem that many
landlords Encounter of our tenants
skipping Out On A month's rent we also
have a better understanding of what
normal wear and tear looks like so this
is not an anti-landlord bill
fully understand where they're coming
from and have a new perspective on that
um
but landlords already do this they
already give their tenants notice of
higher rent this would accelerate that
process by 15 days so it's something
they already do something they're
familiar doing and it's as simple as
sending an email
so
um under this you know this legislature
under both parties has really struggled
with how to address the housing crisis
in the state it happened last term uh
it's happened this term there's just no
easy way to do it
um this isn't a Panacea this isn't going
to solve it but I think this will take
some of the pressure off give tenants
who are priced out forced to move for
any number of reasons they're they're
building sold
um their landlord decided to renovate
any number of reasons somebody is forced
to move this would give them a little
bit of extra time to find replacement
housing ideally in their same Community
but hopefully uh not too far off
so uh with that I'll I'll stop
um and I'm happy to take questions
any questions for representative
representative De Lorenzo make a mistake
yeah
and thank you representative Conley
really quick question
um you mentioned that sending the 45-day
notice of a rent increase is as simple
as sending an email
um I agree but not everyone has email so
you would really need to back that up
with a paper
correct
thank you representative the
notification
um could happen in more than one more
than one mode could be email could be
mail could be something as simple as
placing a piece of paper in your
tenant's mailbox
or any we can all contemplate any number
of ways this could be satisfied
if I could just follow up on that I
think that it says here that it shall be
served in accordance with the provisions
of our state 545.
Mr chairman thank you the point of
saying the email was not that uh to be
blithe or casual it was meant that the
notification with uh
with you know a new lease or something
of those name of that nature could be
done in that form it wouldn't have to be
but it could be done that way
are there any other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
and to the committee I have to leave to
go to my other to go back to my
committee but no that's why I'm rushing
out of here so thank you not a problem
uh representative Perez asked for three
minutes
good afternoon my name is Maria Perez
um is the representative for district 23
Milford New Hampshire I'm here in
support of hb12 and I'm one of the
co-sponsors of this bill
um what we're seeing right now we did a
situation that people having a hard time
finding uh
place to live in there are the amount of
money that it has to pay for the
apartments are this is I think it is
critical for landlords to send a
notification 45 days before they uh they
uh do any changes to the rent
um that will help people to decide if
something that they're going to be able
to afford that's something that it has
to move out of their uh area or they you
know like how hopefully they can find
out an apartment in their same location
but it is critical for people to have
enough time to decide those type of
things especially with the economy that
we have right now people they're having
a hard time even um even in my town uh
the two-bedroom apartment is 1600
um for two bathrooms and most of them
they go from eighteen hundred dollars or
up and and I think this is not in
anti-landlaw like someone else say you
know I I work for the rental property
management in Manchester previously and
and I understand you know the landlords
that you know they they already get the
notice but I think it's critical for
them for um for the people who rent the
apartments to have enough time to make
the decision that they can afford at the
apartment
any questions for representative Perez
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you
representative Nicole Klein Knight
she just
uh Nick Norman
thank you
again for the opportunity to speak
before the committee
so again being an advocate for landlords
across the state of New Hampshire
so one of the concerns that we have with
bills like this is they're what we would
call Band-Aid bills and
is unquestionable that we have
an issue with the affordability of
housing
we would like to see the affordability
of housing addressed in a way that
actually works and creates more
affordable housing
many of the bills like this will worsen
the situation
it's an immediate
it looks like an immediate little fix
but it always backfires into
increased rents and complications so
just consider if a
rent increases 45 days
from the landlord to the tenant but the
tenant's notice to the landlord is 30
days
then the tenant starts looking 45 days
out
but on average they're finding things
that are not available until
you know 30 30 days
it creates an imbalance in the notice
it forces a worsening of the demand for
housing because they're going out to
look but the housing is not available
yet because the notices are different
if you have
45 days there's a percentage of tenants
that just stop paying their rent
those are the Bad actors of course
but if it's 45 days now that unpaid rent
spans two months
that two-month loss has to be made up
somehow
of course that's going to be increased
rents
two months loss is 16 percent
that's a large amount to make up
any time you create more restriction
it always comes back eventually in
increased rents
we need to fix affordable housing
what we need is more housing
we need to not be doing this little
thing and that little thing and that
little thing that just imbalances the
laws and makes things worse and
increases rents we need to fix
affordable housing like really we need
to create more housing that's where our
focus should be
not in little little bills like this
there's one other thing I wanted to say
yeah so
you may think it's small but this is the
foot in the door to regulating rents and
rent control
and that that's always been a bad idea
proven out over and over and over and
over
so I'd be really happy to take any
questions and answer any questions
representative Sylvia
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Norman
for taking my question thank you
it's January 12th so if I were to
go looking for an apartment today
I would find one that I like I apply for
it
the landlord would have perhaps a
hundred other applicants
is that landlord going to hold that
apartment for me until
March 1st
not in the slightest way that's actually
on my page and going fast I skip over
things but yes that's that's absolutely
true no landlord is going to be holding
an apartment vacant
for an increasing amount of time like
the department the landlord's not going
to hold the apartment vacant for 45 days
not a chance
May
so
if I really wanted that apartment I
might have to pay for February's rent to
have it held for me and that would hold
an apartment vacant
for
a period of time times how many
apartments are turning over
that is actually happening we're seeing
in my business people there is a large
I'm I'm telling you it's true there's a
lot of people looking for apartments
clamoring her apartments and often
because we don't have enough affordable
housing it's not that they're paying
increased rent
for a time they're paying double rent
just to get the housing
they'll pay a month's rent sometimes
just to hold that housing so they have
it
it's an issue I mean really we need to
do something that builds more housing
to ease this issue it's all supply and
demand
all this stuff here is like have you
ever tried to
put water let's say in a balloon and
squeeze water
you know it doesn't squeeze it's like
this you you do one thing to push the
market one way and you say well that
that'll help and pretty soon something
pops out over here
you can't be doing these kind of little
I think like this we have to really
affix affordable housing by creating
more housing
any other questions yes representative
Horrigan
um
I mean I I mean I I agree
I agreed that uh you know we have to
create more affordable housing but my my
question the reality of this is that um
you can basically
you can basically rent all of your uh
all of your uh inventory at a very high
price certainly very high compared to
what people are being paid even with uh
even with wages going up because of
what's happening with the labor market
so
there's a fact that the prices are so
high and the demand is so high does that
does that make the uh effect of uh and
then but then you're saying then of
course you point out and understand why
you're pointing out that any demand we
make in you on the landlords will raise
their costs so is that
worse in a situation like this where you
have uh you know where you can you know
basically rent out every apartment you
have at a very high price that's like
probably more than the average working
person can afford is that so that
situation where you're very high prices
and very high demand is that
make it better or worse when we uh
when we impose some Demand on you that
increase your costs
I'm not quite clear every time every
time we do something every time we
propose something that imposes
an extra costs on landlords and this
seems like
um
this particular one seems like a fairly
low cost to me you then say we're gonna
have to rate this will raise rents even
higher because of the extra cost and
that's um yeah we well you come in you
can't and you know I I respect where
you're coming from and occasionally you
relent like a few years ago with the bed
bugs you actually agreed to do something
about it but um so it was defected these
higher costs these additional costs made
is that made worse by the fact that the
rents are so extraordinarily High
compared to what working people can
afford or is that uh
or does that make it like a little bit
less bad for you guys but still bad so
I don't know okay I'm still unsure of
the question but but what I would say is
that rents are much higher than they
were yes the the what landlords have to
do to comply with regulations uh lead
paint removal
um fire codes
increase taxes increase Insurance
everything's going up yeah you can't buy
a burger for the same what you did you
know two years ago so and that's just a
fact of reality and any time that some
kind of
limitation regulation barrier is put on
landlords then that makes landlords less
desirable to create and offer housing is
is not easy to be a landlord oh yeah I
understand
you don't want to create barriers to
being a landlord what you want is to put
your focus on creating more housing
and I'm saying that not because it
benefits me if there was more housing I
would get less rent
right because of supply and demand but
that's as a society what we need that's
where we need to put our Focus
um can I follow up to
but your your prices are I think you
have to admit you're
prices are at least from the renter's
perspective extremely high
extraordinarily high it's epic because
you have to make them extraordinly high
because we're posting so many costs on
you or is it simply because there's a
a shortage of uh that there's more
demand than Supply and you can charge
more because the market will bear more I
understand that question yeah thanks so
I finally got around
thank you very much for the question so
it's both yeah right there's no question
about it that supply and demand
it's just pure economics that's going to
increase prices so if we had more Supply
that would help to stabilize the prices
um I have seen markets where the rents
have come down by the way over the years
and the increased regulations
definitely adds to the costs
for sure the lead Bill increased the
rents a lot
by the way
what's that um yes and of course
probably another part of it is to when
people are playing High rents don't they
also probably demand more so like if you
were
paying a hundred dollars a month for
your apartment you might put up with the
lead paint and mediator yourself or just
live with it where if it's two thousand
look by God you're gonna get that lead
paint out of there and the tenants gonna
do everything they can to get rid of it
I agree that that's true and that's what
we are seeing like we're needing to
renovate more than we used to and we are
and and we are removing the lead paint
and we're we're on a much higher
percentage of lead beta departments than
we used to be and that's great
I mean in terms of my liability
thank you thanks Jim
representative di Lorenzo thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman I feel like the
discussion is going kind of off tracks
because what we're talking about is a
difference in
I noticed
of a rent to increase going from 30 days
to 45 days like 30 to 45 that's 15 days
and we're
we're talking around that right now we
need to get back to the Germaine
discussions thank you
thank you
is there any other questions for Mr
Norman
seeing none thank you for yourself today
representative
uh Nicole Knight Klein
fine night excuse me
thank you so much members of this
committee and Mr chairman and
representative Nicole Klein knight from
Hillsboro District 11 in Manchester I'm
one of the co-sponsors of this bill I
just want to address some of the things
that the last speaker said
um they kept saying that there's a
supply problem there's not enough houses
that has nothing to do with how far you
notify a renter that's not going to
change unless we attack it in a
different way
what this does do is notify a renter
that they can save they can start
chipping away so they can actually
afford if the rent is going to go up or
if they are going to need a security
deposit for another place to live as
representative Sylvia pointed out you
have a hundred people or more than that
applying for one apartment
the the landlord is gonna get somebody
this does not hurt any landlords this is
a respectful way to keep people from
being homeless and as you know and all
the members of this body know
homelessness is out of control
especially in Manchester
this is
not going to be a burden financially for
a I'm a renter and
um
we have really good communication
because I'm an honest renter I pay on
time if for instance the property taxes
go up like they usually do because we
don't have any other tax pull to pull
from they will have to notify me in
sadness they don't want to do that and
fact many of my constituents that our
landlords have reached out to me
concerned about the property tax and how
that's going to impact them how they
aren't making any money off the current
situation and how they're going to have
to increase rent this at least a bare
minimum gives people a fighting chance
to stay off of the street and I want to
point out that the median income in
Manchester is thirty two thousand
dollars the median rental for an
apartment is over two grand
so
like I said there's much more demand
than Supply
landlords are not going to have a
problem thank you so much Mr chairman
are there any questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and
all right the last card I have is Alyssa
margolin
thank you Mr chairman again for the
record Alyssa Morgan I serve as director
of housing action New Hampshire most of
the members of housing action New
Hampshire are landlords of affordable
housing properties and we do support
House Bill 1200. we have supported
different versions of this bill there
are other versions that connected notice
to more significant increases as
attempts to just
um to add uh 15 days and align with uh
with other New England states I just
thought I would share some data around
our renter population for the committee
about 29 of all Granite Staters lit rent
so their homes are rented I think that's
somewhat surprising because in many
towns you don't necessarily a lot of our
rentals are are owned by smaller
landlords who don't really recognize it
as as rental properties but 29 29 of our
population does rent their homes of all
of our renters over 50 percent are what
we called housing costs burdened meaning
they're paying too much of their income
per month towards housing costs and so
we know that for some extremely low
income people that are creating
um really financially fragile situations
because of increases in rent they can be
paying close to 80 percent of monthly
income towards housing costs but we know
that this is a little confusing but we
know that half of our renters pay over
50 and the standard for affordability is
is closer to 30 in including um
uh uh you know costs for for uh heat
electricity and um on internet
um so
uh given this if I you know there's
really not a broad Statewide tenant
organizing organization in our state and
housing action New Hampshire represents
landlords and affordable housing
developers but I would say that if we
had tenants here today they might tell
you that notice is a gift I mean when if
you want to put your yourself in the
shoes of say a single mom with some kids
and you find out that you're going to
have to pay an increase in rent that
notice might allow you to seek other
sources of income to me you might decide
to stay just to have to plan and find
the time to search for an apartment and
so we see this in terms of our eviction
prevention work and ending homelessness
we see this as as a part of that
solution in in the eviction prevention
and housing stability work that we try
to do as we navigate the housing crisis
so I'll conclude my testimony and happy
to take any questions
questions
is margolin
yes representative D Lorenzo
Miss McGowan is it still realistic that
the tenant rent burden be no more than
30 percent of the income
well I mean I think that's a fair
question because I think many of us have
lived through times in our lives when we
know that we've paid more than 30
percent but it's defined in statute that
affordability is 30 a voucher for
example would cover 70 if you were to be
lucky enough to just cure a voucher and
be able to find a place to use it uh on
them in the market
um and you know it's I think it's also
fair to say that renter income has gone
up we know wages have gone up
um but they have not kept pace with the
cost of the major increases in housing
costs so I don't have uh I'm not looking
at the sheet now it used to be that
renter income in New Hampshire was 14 an
hour and uh housing wage what you need
to earn per hour to afford a typical
two-bedroom apartment was 23 an hour my
guess is that 14 has gone up a couple
dollars and then um just because we know
that there are wage increases in a lot
of the hospitality industry and
um as and Retail as we try to retain and
sustain Workforce here in the state but
I don't think it's kept pace but you I
do think it's still a fair measure of
affordability the more you spend on
housing the less you have to spend in
other areas so it hurts the economy
overall if you're spending all of your
monthly income on housing costs you're
don't you have less to give to your
local community you've left to go out to
a restaurant you know less to support
the local baseball team and
um and and provide clothes and medicine
and other Essentials
other
again I guess my question comes down to
this in terms of looking at the bill
this does nothing about
the cost of the housing
in the sense that it doesn't control the
costs and it specifically provides that
you can raise any amount you want
basically
it only
addresses the timing of increases
and basically in terms of two weeks or
15 days for the most part
so
and the representation has been that
this will have an impact on homelessness
and I'm trying to figure out in my mind
whether
simply providing 15 more days or two
weeks
is going to have any substantial impact
upon
homelessness
I do think it would be a tool in the
toolbox for eviction prevention eviction
eviction prevention equates to
homelessness prevention the best way at
preventing the increase of homelessness
is to prevent people from becoming
homeless in the first place it's not a
it's not it's very hard once you're
homeless to get back into the market
it's very hard to find a landlord who's
going to rent to you when your address
is currently the shelter it's really
hard on kids like homelessness is really
damaging to kids as much as folks try to
engage in evidence evidence-based
programming do I think this is the
Panacea and the answer to everything
absolutely not but it's a tool I don't
think it's onerous my members don't find
it onerous they're they already work
they do raise rents and they already you
know work to provide notice to make sure
that people aren't displaced and I do
think if we had more representation
today out of hearing from people who
really live this
um that they would tell you that that
time is helpful
in terms of the
the parts that are part of your
Coalition yeah
and I but are most of the are those
government subsidized
so yeah
um
our Coalition is made up of those who
develop manage and own affordable
housing properties and they are mission
oriented landlords so they're in the
business of making sure that people can
afford and sustain housing even some
cases they'll provide housing for folks
earning up to 120 of every meeting
income
um but they're in the business of making
sure that we have the affordable housing
stock in New Hampshire they are in favor
of this bill they think that notice is
helpful they already do that that's
their already their practice because of
their their mission oriented so they
they see this as a way of asking others
in the private Market to do the same
I don't think that they would say it's
gonna it would be a cure-all but I think
that they would say it's a tool in the
toolbox other states already have
um this kind of notice thank you for the
question
thank you
any other questions
thank you for your testimony again today
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 1200
yes have you filled out a pink card I
did fill out a big card okay it was much
earlier on today I gave it to a
different clerk than uh rep okay but you
know and I hate to make you do that
again but could you do that again
because I don't seem to have it for
somebody you want to do that afterwards
afterwards yes I can definitely do that
again that'd be great thank you thank
you uh for the committee for having me
here today um my name is Jonah wheeler
I'm with rights and democracy but I come
here today as a citizen and a student
from Peterborough New Hampshire
um I I am a tenant I am living this
experience right now or rather my mother
is a tenant and I come in lieu of of her
she's a single mother who cannot be here
today so if I have the free time I'll
I'll do it
um I can say that this is
I wouldn't say that this would end
homelessness uh and I wouldn't I don't
have any data or anything to to prove
anything near that fact but as someone
who has been homeless and has had rent
fall through and has seen that happen in
the effects that it has on a whole
family
I can tell you two weeks is a nice
cushion to have if we were low on rent
or about to be evicted having that two
weeks would be a perfect Comfort cushion
in order to figure something out figure
a separate situation out if it might not
be staying in that house but it's having
a place to stay if you're not in that
house I've been in that situation a
couple of times where you have housing
fall through immediately or close to
immediately and then in that specific
situation we were forced to live in a a
tent community in Greenville I think it
was so as much as young families
families with single mothers and and
small children can avoid that and try to
find a different situation stay in the
house until they've found a different
situation I think that would be
beneficial to the working class in this
state it wouldn't address homelessness
wouldn't address the price of housing I
think that has to be addressed in
different legislation but in providing a
comfort to those disadvantaged people
before they're out on the street this is
a great piece of legislation for that
and yeah with that thank you I'll take
questions if you have them yeah
Joe and I found your card and I had
called you earlier on a different
hearing but I see you signed up for this
hearing and that was my fault well I was
also in uh the room 100 over there so I
was gone thank you thank you very much
any any questions
seeing none thank you Mr Wheeler thank
you
and there was somebody else who had
their hand up yes sir
I have a bad pin card right here
um so for the record uh my name is
Brandon Lemay from Manchester New
Hampshire I'm representing rights and
democracy and the Manchester housing
Alliance
uh so first off um I think if I could
summarize this bill in one word I would
say reasonable
as an affordable housing Advocate I
would like to see restrictions on you
know how much that rent could be raised
but I understand that that might not be
in agreement with everybody in this room
so rather than you know thinking about
the art of what's perfect I would rather
like to achieve the art of what's
achievable and I think this is
completely reasonable here
and I think this bill would benefit two
main types of people that I've
encountered uh while I go door to door
talking to renters in middle class and
lower income neighborhoods
the first group are the month of the
month renters
and it's pretty common now to see
monthly increases I was talking to a
tenant yesterday on the west side of
Manchester who said that her rent has
gone up twenty dollars a month every
month for the past three months
and I I'm a big proponent of personal
responsibility and part of that means
budgeting
and I just think it makes it difficult
to budget when your rent is going up
every single month I'm somebody I like
to know you know I plan out when I get
my pay when I get my direct deposit when
the rent's coming out and I can budget
around accordingly I just don't know how
and increase every 30 days can actually
be something I could manage around
I think with these extra 15 days that
we'd be getting uh you know maybe you
could think about how to pick up an
extra shift or maybe you can use those
extra 15 days to think about and apply
to more you know Apartments
um and I think the second group that
this would apply to a lot of renters
myself included have a clause in our
lease that our rent can be increased at
any time during the duration
um it just it really affects a lot of
renters here
um and again I just don't know how
somebody can be expected to take
responsibility over their finances when
they can't predict you know their
biggest expense
um and I did want to address a previous
speaker about this possibly raising the
price of rent
um we we live in a market economy and
the price of rent is dictated by how
much renters can pay and maybe some
expenses here and there for landlords
like property taxes
um you know repairs to the roof and
stuff like that I think as we've
discussed landlords have a lot of
Leverage right now they can easily rent
out that next apartment
um you know to the next person that's
willing to pay that rent increase so I'm
not necessarily worried about this
having such a negative impact on
landlords especially when you weigh it
against how much the market favors them
right now
so I'll end my testimony there and open
up to any questions
thank you Mr Lemay
any questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
okay uh is there anybody else who wishes
to testify on House Bill 1200 seeing no
one I declare the hearing closed
I don't know if there's any other
business that we need to address if not
then the committee will be recessed
until nine o'clock tomorrow morning
thank you
it's gonna be longer tomorrow
tomorrow
well can we use them though
I know because I am together I know but
oh I didn't know they learned sorry
you might want to grab it
I am
coming yes I saw that
at noon
yeah but the committee
outside
state federal of establishing